SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. DURAZO.
EGGMAN GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO CIERTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND THE GUESTS.
BEYOND THE RAIL. PLEASE RISE FOR
THE PLEDGE OF FOR A PRAYER,
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. ALLEGIANCE, SISTER.
THANK YOU. SO WE GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. GOD OF ALL CREATION.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS NEW
WEEK. FILL US WITH WONDER AND
GRATITUDE FOR THE ABUNDANCE OF
YOUR BLESSINGS. TEACH US TO
DELIGHT IN THE ANTICIPATION OF
THIS DAY'S SURPRISES. WE LIFT
OUR VOICES TO PRAISE YOU FOR THE
BEAUTY OF THE EARTH, FOR THE
HARVESTS OF FIELD AND ORCHARD.
GIVE US HEARTS THAT LONG TO
SHARE WITH THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM
WANT AND HOPELESSNESS. BRING THE
HEALING LIGHT OF YOUR PRESENCE
INTO THE STRUGGLES OF OUR LIVES,
SO THAT BY OUR EFFORTS FOR THE
COMMON GOOD, OUR WORLD WILL DRAW
CLOSER TO HEALING, PEACE, AND
JUSTICE. AMEN AMEN. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH US FOR ALL
PEOPLE.
COLLEAGUES, WE'RE GOING TO BE
JUMPING INTO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR WHERE WE WILL BE
RECOGNIZING SEVEN OF OUR
OUTGOING COLLEAGUES. FOR EACH
MEMBER, WE WILL BE RECOGNIZING
WE WILL HAVE TWO SPEAKERS. EACH
SPEAKER WILL SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES. EACH SPEAKER WILL SPEAK
FOR TWO MINUTES, AND THEN THE
MEMBER WILL SPEAK FOR THREE
MEMBERS. THREE MINUTES. THE
OUTGOING MEMBER WILL SPEAK FOR
THREE MINUTES RESPECTFULLY
ASKING THAT WE STAY WITHIN THAT
TIME FRAME, AS CLOSE AS
POSSIBLE. SENATOR DALI IS GOING
TO LEAD US IN STAYING CLOSE TO
THAT TIME FRAME. FIRST, WE'RE
GOING TO BE HONORING SENATOR
EGGMAN. AND BEFORE WE DO THAT,
WE ACTUALLY HAVE I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE A SPECIAL GUEST WE
HAVE ON THE FLOOR. SENATOR
GLAZER HAS BROUGHT HIS DAUGHTER,
ALEX TODAY. SENATOR ALEX,
WELCOME. OKAY, MOVING BACK TO
OUR RECOGNITIONS, WE'RE LIKE I
MENTIONED, WE'RE KICKING OFF
WITH RECOGNIZING SENATOR EGGMAN.
OUR FIRST SPEAKER IS GOING TO BE
SENATOR ATKINS TO KICK US OFF.
SENATOR ATKINS, WHEN YOU'RE
READY, PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
REMARKS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. PERMISSION TO HOLD A
SMALL PROP? WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WELL. THANK YOU. I NEED TO HOLD
THIS EGGMAN FOR STATE SENATE
STRESS EGG. BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I GET THIS RIGHT.
AND I'VE HAD THIS FOR A WHILE.
COLLEAGUES, I HAD TO MAKE SOME
COUNTLESS DECISIONS AS PRO TEM.
MANY WERE HARD AND SOME WERE
EASY. ONE OF THE EASIEST WAS
NAMING SENATOR SUSAN TALAMANTES
EGGMAN TO CHAIR THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE FROM HER DAYS
AS A MEDIC IN THE U.S. ARMY TO
HER WORK AS A MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER AND MEDICAL SOCIAL
WORKER. I KNEW SHE HAD THE
EXPERIENCE AND THE EMPATHY TO
SHAPE THE HEALTH CARE DECISIONS
THAT WE MAKE AS A LEGISLATURE, I
KNEW SHE HAD FIERCE DEDICATION
TO EXPANDING THE VISION AND
MAGNIFYING OUR EMPHASIS ON
MENTAL HEALTH. A BADLY NEEDED
AND LONG OVERDUE PART OF THE
HEALTH CARE EQUATION. I ALSO
KNEW SHE HAD THE GUMPTION TO GET
THE JOB DONE. YOU DON'T COME OUT
OF NOWHERE AS A LESBIAN, A
LATINA WIN A SEAT ON THE
STOCKTON CITY COUNCIL. YOUR
FIRST TIME OUT. SUSAN TALAMANTES
EGGMAN DID. SHE SHOWED SHE HAS
THE SPARK OF THE SPECIAL FROM
DAY ONE, AND I AM ALSO
INCREDIBLY LUCKY TO HAVE SERVED
WITH HER IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY.
HER LEADERSHIP BROUGHT ABOUT
LANDMARK CHANGES TO HOW WE AID
THOSE NEARING THE END OF THEIR
LIVES IN CALIFORNIA. LANDMARK.
SHE'S BEEN A CHAMPION FOR
DIVERSION WHEN IT MAKES MORE
SENSE THAN DETENTION, AND I
TRULY BELIEVE HER LEADERSHIP IS
ONE OF THE REASONS WE NOW HAVE
CARE. COURTS AND IN THIS LAST
YEAR, WE SAW HER ONCE AGAIN
SHOULDERING ANOTHER TOUGH BURDEN
BY TAKING ON THE DIFFICULT
ISSUES RELATING TO
CONSERVATORSHIP. NOW MY MEMORY'S
A LITTLE FUZZY, BUT I REMEMBER
THE SPEECH. I THINK WE WERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY. I THINK IT WAS A
PRESS CONFERENCE IN ROOM 317 ON
THE LGBTQ CAUCUS, ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE LATEST ATTACKS ON
OUR COMMUNITY'S RIGHTS. AT THAT
PRESS CONFERENCE, WHEN SUSAN
CAME UP TO THE PODIUM, SHE
EMOTIONALLY SHARED THE STORY OF
HOW THE DECISION HAD JUST BEEN
MADE THAT SHE AND RENEE WOULD
HAVE TO TAKE ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF RAISING A
RELATIVE'S CHILD AS THEIR OWN.
IN THAT MOMENT, SUSAN TALAMANTES
EGGMAN WAS THE LIVING, BREATHING
EMBODIMENT OF FAMILY VALUES.
FAMILY VALUES IN ACTION. I WAS
SO PROUD OF HER THEN, AND I'M
PROUD OF HER NOW. WATCHING EMMY
GROW INTO THE YOUNG WOMAN SHE IS
TODAY, I THINK OF THERE'S SO
MANY TIMES THAT WE HAVE HEARD ON
THIS FLOOR, SENATOR EGGMAN, GET
UP WITH NO PREPARED REMARKS TO
MAKE HER COMMENTS ABOUT
SOMETHING INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
AND NEVER HAVE I EVER HEARD A
BETTER FLOOR SPEECH THAN IN
THOSE MOMENTS. I SAID IT BEFORE
A PHD, A SOCIAL WORKER, A
TEACHER, SMALL FARMER, RURAL AG
COUNTRY THAT SHE COMES FROM, A
LESBIAN, A WOMAN, A LATINA. THE
LIVED EXPERIENCE THAT YOU BRING
TO THIS BODY, THE PROFESSIONAL
SKILLS, HAS MADE YOU INVALUABLE
TO THE LEGISLATURE. 40 YEARS
AGO, THIS MONTH, A YOUNG WOMAN
IN NEW YORK CITY WAS GETTING
READY TO MAKE HER FIRST MOVIE.
HER NAME WAS MADONNA, AND THE
MOVIE WAS DESPERATELY SEEKING
SUSAN. SENATOR, YOU AND I, ALL
OF US HAVE COME A LONG WAY SINCE
THE 1980S. AS I STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO SAY, DESPERATELY
MISSING SUSAN IS GOING TO BE ONE
OF THE MAIN DRAWBACKS TO OUR NOT
SHARING, SERVING AND SHARING
TOGETHER IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. AND ALL OF YOU WILL BE
DESPERATELY MISSING SUSAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATORS, THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LOT OF APPLAUSE. IT'S WELCOMED.
LET'S HOLD OUR FINAL HOUR
APPLAUSE TO THE AFTER THE MEMBER
IS DONE SPEAKING OUR NEXT
SPEAKER FOR SENATOR EGGMAN IS
GOING TO BE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I AM HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO SHARE 12 YEARS OF MY LIFE AND
OUR LIFE IN THE LEGISLATURE. I
WANT TO JUST START OUT. I WENT
BACK AND LOOKED THROUGH ALL THE
TEXT MESSAGES THAT WE'VE SENT
BACK AND FORTH, HAD SOME TEARS
SOME TIMES THAT WERE TOUGH. BUT
I WANT TO JUST SHARE WHO IS
SUSAN TALAMANTES EGGMAN? WHO IS
SHE? WELL, I'LL TELL YOU WHO SHE
IS. SHE'S A VETERAN WHO CAME TO
BEAVER TO THE BIG VALLEY HIGH
SCHOOL AND SPOKE AT THE ASSEMBLY
AS A VETERAN FOR THE VETERANS
DAY GET TOGETHER ALL THE WAY TO
BEAVER. SHE WAS THE FIRST MEMBER
WHEN WE WERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
THAT CAME TO MY HOME AND STAYED
WITH ME AND GOT TO KNOW A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT MY DISTRICT. WHAT DOES
SHE DO? SHE LOVES TO BAKE. SHE
MAKES THE BEST JALAPENO BREAD IN
TOWN. I WILL TELL YOU THAT. AND
WHAT ELSE DOES SHE DO? SHE SHE
CHECKS ON YOU ALL THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR. HOW ARE YOU DOING? IF
YOU'RE SICK, IF YOU'RE MISSING.
SHE'S THE FIRST ONE TO TEXT YOU
AND SAY, ARE YOU OKAY? WHAT'S
GOING ON THROUGH COVID?
CONSTANTLY TEXTING ME THROUGH
THE MEDICAL ISSUES WITH MY
FAMILY, CONSTANTLY TEXTING ME.
AND THEN AS A MOTHER. SO WE WERE
BOTH RAISING TEENAGE DAUGHTERS.
AND SO WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THE
GREAT THINGS THAT HAPPEN AS
RAISING CHILDREN TOGETHER. BUT I
WANT TO SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, IN
LIFE YOU'RE LUCKY IF YOU GET
FIVE PEOPLE THAT YOU CAN REALLY
COUNT ON THAT YOU KNOW THAT IF
SOMETHING'S REALLY BAD HAPPENING
OR YOU NEED SOMEBODY TO TALK TO,
YOU CAN PICK UP THE PHONE AND
TALK TO SUSAN. EGGMAN IS ONE OF
THE FIVE ON MY HAND THAT I KNOW
I CAN TALK TO ANY TIME ABOUT
ANYTHING. NO MATTER WHAT'S
HAPPENING OVER THE LAST 12
YEARS, SHE'S CHAMPIONED VETERANS
ISSUES. SHE HAS CHAMPIONED LGBTQ
ISSUES. SHE STOOD UP FOR THE
FAMILY FARM. THANK YOU, BY THE
WAY, AS A FAMILY FARMER, SHE'S
ALSO PERSUADED MEMBERS OF OUR
SIDE OF THE AISLE, MAINLY ME, A
LOT, I THINK, BUT WE WERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY, SHE SAID TO ME, HEY,
WHERE ARE YOU? WHERE IS YOUR
CAUCUS? WHERE ARE YOU AT ON THIS
BILL? AND SHE WOULD SAY, YOU
KNOW, WE'D HAVE A POSE OR
WHATEVER IT WAS, AND SEVERAL
TIMES SHE'D SAY, LISTEN TO MY
SPEECH BECAUSE I'M REALLY. SHE
WOULD SAY TO ME, LISTEN TO MY
SPEECH. AND SO IN THE ASSEMBLY,
I VOTED FOR TWO OF HER BILLS.
AND I THINK IT WAS SOMETHING
CRAZY, LIKE, YOU KNOW, GIVE
SOMEBODY WITH MATERNITY LEAVE
WITHOUT PAY A FEW EXTRA DAYS,
SOMETHING THAT A NORMAL EMPLOYER
PROBABLY SHOULD DO ANYWAY.
ANYWAY, I VOTED FOR THE BILLS
AND THEN I GOT THE SCORECARD AT
THE END OF THE YEAR, AND I GOT
SCORED DOWN FROM THE CAL
CHAMBER. I GOT AN 80% BECAUSE I
VOTED FOR TWO BILLS, BOTH BILLS,
AND IT WAS SO I SENT A TEXT TO
HER, I SAID, HEY, MY SCORE WENT
DOWN AND SHE SAID THEIR
RIGHTEOUS BILLS. BUT ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT, THERE WAS
TIMES WHEN I HAD BILLS THAT
KNOCKED HER SCORE CARD DOWN,
SIERRA CLUB, ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS, AND SHE KNEW THE ISSUES,
AND SHE VOTED FOR THOSE BILLS
BECAUSE IT WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. THAT'S WHO SUSAN EGGMAN
IS. JUST A COUPLE MORE SECONDS.
MEMBERS LAST YEAR, I THINK, WAS
THE DEFINING MOMENT TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW SHE WORKS ACROSS
THE AISLE AND HOW SHE HER
RESPECT FOR HER WAS WHEN SHE HAD
SB 326 LAST YEAR AND WE HAD AN
OPPOSE ON IT, AND IT WAS A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OUT OF HERE, WITH
MANY MEMBERS STANDING UP AND
SAYING, WE TRUST THE AUTHOR OF
THAT BILL. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
GOING TO SUPPORT THAT BILL. WE
COME FROM DIFFERENT SIDES OF THE
AISLE, BUT I THINK WHAT I'VE
LEARNED FROM SUSAN MAINLY IS
THAT IT'S WHAT THIS PLACE NEEDS
MORE OF. PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE AND
STILL WORK TOGETHER. SO FOR THE
LAST 12 YEARS, MY FRIEND, I'VE
WATCHED YOU WRITE YOUR STORY AS
A VETERAN, A MOTHER, A
LEGISLATOR, AND MUCH, MUCH MORE.
I JUST WANT TO BE THERE IN THE
FUTURE TO WATCH YOU WRITE THE
REST OF YOUR STORY FOR US TO ALL
WATCH. I WANT TO HOLD YOU UP
WHEN YOU'RE WINNING, AND I WANT
TO COME ALONGSIDE YOU WHEN
YOU'RE STRUGGLING. THANK YOU FOR
BEING SUCH A WONDERFUL, AWESOME
FRIEND AND I THINK A REAL ROLE
MODEL TO WHAT THIS PLACE NEEDS
MORE OF. THANK YOU SUSAN. I LOVE
YOU. WELL, THANK YOU ALL. THANK
YOU BOTH VERY MUCH. I APPRECIATE
IT, YOU NEVER YOU NEVER THINK
ABOUT MAKING THIS END SPEECH AND
IT COMES FASTER THAN YOU THINK.
FIRST OF ALL, IT SEEMS SO FAR
AWAY. NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, IT'S
HERE. AND SO THEN I WAS
WONDERING WHEN I THOUGHT I HAD
TO SAY SOME THINGS. LIKE WHO?
WHO IS MY AUDIENCE, RIGHT.
BECAUSE THAT'S ALWAYS IMPORTANT
WHEN WE WHEN WE SPEAK, WHEN WE
GIVE, WHEN WE GIVE VOICE TO WHAT
IS IN US. LIKE WHO? WHAT AM I
TRYING TO MOVE? WHO AM I TRYING
TO MOVE? WHAT AM I TRYING TO
ACHIEVE WITH THESE WORDS, AND
THEN I JUST KIND OF REFLECTED
THAT'S HOPEFULLY HOW I'VE TRIED
TO SERVE HERE IS REALLY TRYING
TO FIND SOMETHING THAT BRINGS US
TOGETHER, SOMETHING THAT CAN
TOUCH EVERY ONE OF US AND REMIND
US ALL OF OUR SHARED HUMANITY.
WHEN I NEVER INTENDED TO RUN FOR
POLITICS, WHEN I WAS ON THE
STOCKTON CITY COUNCIL FOR TWO
TERMS, AND WHEN I CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE, I WAS ON THE
COUNCIL OF A CITY THAT WAS GOING
INTO BANKRUPTCY, WHERE WE HAD
UNSUSTAINABLE STRUCTURES IN OUR
IN OUR CONTRACTS. WE WERE
CUTTING POLICE AND CLOSING
LIBRARIES. IN THE YEAR THAT WE
WERE BREAKING THE RECORD WITH 70
VIOLENT MURDERS FROM GUNS, IT
WAS YOU COULD FEEL IT PALPABLE
ON THE STREETS. THE DISTRUST AND
THE AND THE JUST THE MISERY THAT
WE ALL FELT AT THAT TIME. AND
STOCKTON WAS VOTED THE MOST
MISERABLE CITY IN THE UNITED
STATES. SO WHEN I CAME HERE, IT
WAS WITH A REAL MISSION, LIKE,
HOW DO I MAKE MY CONSTITUENTS
FEEL SEEN? HOW DO I MAKE THEM
KNOW THEY'RE BEING REPRESENTED,
THAT SOMEBODY IS SPEAKING FOR
THEM, THAT SOMEBODY SEES THEM
AND IS GOING TO TRY TO MAKE
THINGS BETTER IN ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT WAYS FOR THEM. AND MY
WAY OF BEING ABLE TO DO THAT IS
INVITING YOU ALONG ON MY JOURNEY
WITH ME AND ENTERING INTO
RELATIONSHIP WITH ME. SO THEN
HOPEFULLY THE THINGS THAT I TRY
TO ADVANCE, YOU CAN SEE THEM IN
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND IN YOUR
LIVES THAT WE TRY TOGETHER
COLLECTIVELY TO MAKE PEOPLE
BETTER. WE ARE SO PRIVILEGED TO
WORK IN A PLACE LIKE THIS WHERE
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE MEANS TO
HELP PEOPLE TO CHANGE THINGS, TO
MOVE A POSITION FORWARD AND
DON'T PIGEONHOLE YOURSELF. NEVER
PIGEONHOLE YOURSELF. I CAME IN
AS A, YOU KNOW, AS A AS AN
EDUCATOR, AS A SOCIAL WORKER. I
HAVE CHAIRED THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE TWICE. I HAVE CHAIRED
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. I HAVE CHAIRED
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY. I
HAVE CHAIRED THE CAUCUS. I HAVE
BEEN THE CHAIR OF THE LGBTQ
CAUCUS, THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
2018. THAT WAS NO FUN, THAT WAS
NO FUN, AND ALL OF THAT.
HOPEFULLY YOU BRING YOURSELF TO
IT THAT HOW DO WE ALL GET HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE DO OUR BEST IN
EVERY KIND OF PLACE? HOW DO WE
BE THE UTILITY PLAYER THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS US TO BE? AS
FOLKS KNOW, PEOPLE MENTIONED
WHEN I CAME IN, I WAS I MEAN, I
HAD BEEN TOGETHER FOR DECADES
AND I HAD NO INTENTION OF HAVING
CHILDREN. AND IN JUNE, HER
SISTER CONTACTED US AND SAID, I
THINK I'M DYING. AND WE SAID,
YOU'RE NOT. AND SHE DID. WITHIN
TWO MONTHS. AND SO IN AUGUST OF
MY FIRST TERM, 2013, I BECAME A
PARENT OF AN ALMOST FIVE YEAR
OLD. AND THE FOLLOWING MONTH, MY
DAD DIED OF A MASSIVE STROKE. SO
AS WE SIT IN THESE PLACES, WE
ARE LIVING EVERY DAY AND HOW WE
BRING OURSELVES TO THAT
OCCASION, AND HOW DO WE BRING
OUR WHOLE SELVES TO THAT
OCCASION. SO AGAIN, WE'RE NOT
JUST TALKING ABOUT PASSING A
BILL. I'M VERY PROUD OF THE
LEGISLATION I PASSED END OF LIFE
OPTION ACT, THE RIGHT TO REPAIR.
WE'VE GOT THE SAFE INJECTION
SITE TO THE GOVERNOR BROWN'S
DESK, AND HE VETOED IT. THE
CONSERVATORSHIP STUFF. I'VE DONE
ALL THE WORK THAT I'VE DONE WITH
YOU, AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
SUPPORT AND TRUST THAT YOU'VE
ALL PLACED IN ME. AND I WANT TO
SAY A HUGE SHOUT OUT TO MY
STAFF, MY CHIEF OF STAFF, DAVID
STAMMERJOHN, WHO'S BEEN WITH ME
SINCE THE BEGINNING. I'VE HAD A
CONSISTENT DISTRICT STAFF MY
ENTIRE TIME HERE. THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PULL
UP AND MENTOR AND REALLY
HOPEFULLY TEACH PEOPLE WHAT
PUBLIC SERVICE IS ABOUT, WHAT
PUBLIC POLICY IS ABOUT AND MAKE
ALL OF US ALWAYS HOLD ON TO THAT
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO INSTILL IN
OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT IN
CALIFORNIA, YOUR GOVERNMENT SEES
YOU AND FEELS YOU AND DOES
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO MAKE YOUR
LIFE BETTER WITHOUT HARSH WORDS,
WITH FINDING WAYS TO REACH
ACROSS AND NOT DIVIDE. WE ARE
ALWAYS STRONGER TOGETHER AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FRIENDSHIP.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN FOR
YOUR 12 YEARS.
THE NEXT MEMBER WE WILL BE
RECOGNIZING IS THE SENATOR FROM
DISTRICT 25, SENATOR PORTANTINO.
OUR FIRST SPEAKER IS SENATOR
UMBERG. WELL THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TO HONOR MY LANDLORD AND CONDO
MATE, SO SENATOR HAPPENS TO BE A
STATE SENATOR. ALSO, ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS THAT COMES TO MIND
WHEN I THINK BACK OVER THE YEARS
IS, ANTHONY, YOU'RE ONLY HALF
THE MAN YOU USED TO BE. SO IF
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT, YOU
UNDERSTAND AND YOU'VE KNOWN
ANTHONY FOR SEVERAL YEARS, THIS
GUY IS A BICYCLING MANIAC. HE
RIDES TWO, THREE, FOUR HOURS
EVERY DAY. NOW, WHEN HE FIRST
STARTED A FEW YEARS AGO, HE TOLD
ME HE HADN'T RIDDEN 30 MILES IN
30 YEARS. AND THEN HE STARTED
RIDING 50, 60, 70 MILES A DAY. A
PHYSICAL TRANSFORMATION THAT WAS
EXEMPLIFIED BY HIS DEDICATION
AND HIS PERSEVERANCE, WHICH HE
ALSO BRINGS TO OUR BODY. I
LEARNED A NUMBER OF THINGS ABOUT
SENATOR PORTANTINO. ONE IS HOW
PROUD HE IS OF HIS FAMILY, OF
ELLEN, OF SOPHIA AND BELLA. EVEN
HIS CAT OR GRAND CAT. BUT HE
JUST REVELS IN THEIR THEIR LOVE
AND THEIR SUCCESSES. ANTHONY HAD
ME WATCH A EA SPORTS NCAA FINAL
BECAUSE HIS DAUGHTER YOU MAY NOT
KNOW THIS IS AN ESPORTS VARSITY
ATHLETE AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT REDLANDS. HE'S
DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS HERE
THAT WE ALL CAN BE PROUD OF,
THAT HAVE BROUGHT A GREAT DEAL
OF BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIA. BUT
THERE ARE THREE AREAS WHERE I
THINK HE IS BEST WELL KNOWN AT
LEAST WHERE I THINK OF HIM FIRST
IS CHILDREN. WHETHER IT'S THE
LATE START BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT CHILDREN GET ADEQUATE SLEEP
SO THAT THEY CAN PERFORM. HE
TRIED THAT BILL THREE TIMES.
RIGHT NOW HE CAN TELL YOU EVERY
SINGLE HUMAN WHO VOTED FOR AND
DID NOT VOTE FOR THOSE BILLS,
BUT HE WAS A SUCCESS BECAUSE OF
HIS DEDICATION, HIS
PERSEVERANCE. WHETHER IT'S GUNS,
MAKING SURE THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
21 TO BUY A FIREARM, MAKING SURE
THAT YOU CAN'T BRING A FIREARM
TO SCHOOL, MAKING SURE THAT YOU
KNOW HOW TO USE A FIREARM IF YOU
OWN A FIREARM, WHETHER IT'S
MENTAL HEALTH, A PERSONAL ISSUE
FOR SENATOR PORTANTINO, OR
WHETHER IT'S, OR WHETHER IT'S
HOUSING, ALL OF THOSE THINGS,
ALL THOSE THINGS, HE'S BENEFITED
SO, SO MANY CALIFORNIANS,
ARMENIA, THIS GUY IS MISTER
ARMENIA. ASK HIM ANY QUESTION
ABOUT ARMENIA. CURRENT STATUS OR
HISTORY. AND HE KNOWS. NOW,
THERE'S ANOTHER THING AMONG
OTHERS THAT HE'S FAMOUS FOR, AND
THAT'S HIS MEATLOAF. AND I THINK
YOU'RE ALL GOING TO BE
BENEFICIARIES SOON OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO'S MEATLOAF. I'VE GOT
SOMETHING TO SAY, THOUGH,
ANTHONY. I'VE LIVED WITH ANTHONY
NOW FOR SIX YEARS AND SEEN HIS
MEATLOAF. I ACTUALLY DON'T LIKE
MEATLOAF. JUST LETTING YOU KNOW
I LOVE YOU SO. SO YOU COULD GIVE
MY MEATLOAF TO SOMEONE ELSE. I
DIDN'T WANT TO OFFEND YOU HERE
EARLY ON. I DIDN'T WANT YOU TO
ADJUST MY RENT BASED ON ON ON
ISSUES SUCH AS THAT. SO, ANTHONY
IS DEPARTING, BUT NOT FOR LONG.
NOT FOR LONG BECAUSE OF HIS
PASSION FOR CHILDREN, BECAUSE OF
HIS PASSION FOR MENTAL HEALTH,
BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE AREAS IN
WHICH HE'S MADE IMPROVEMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW YOU'LL BE
BACK HERE IN STATE GOVERNANCE.
SO THANK YOU. OUR NEXT SPEAKER
IS GOING TO BE. SENATOR WILK,
THEY'RE TRYING TO FOLLOW
INSTRUCTIONS. SENATOR WILK, I
KNOW WELL, YOU KNOW ME. WELL,
HELLO, MADAM PRESIDENT, MEMBERS
TODAY, I TOO RISE TO RECOGNIZE
OUR COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND,
SENATOR ANTHONY PORTANTINO. WHEN
I THINK OF AND, ANTHONY, I THINK
OF COURAGE, COLLABORATION, AND
KINDNESS AND COURAGE EVERY TIME
ANTHONY WALKS ON THE SENATE
FLOOR, HE SHOWS COURAGE BECAUSE
MOST MEN ARE AFRAID OF COLOR.
ANTHONY IS NOT AFRAID OF COLOR.
AND HE AND WHATEVER HE WEARS,
HE'S ALWAYS ROCKING WITH A PAIR
OF SKECHERS, WHICH SHOWS REAL
COURAGE BECAUSE THAT'S IN
VIOLATION OF THE HOUSE RULES.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW THE HE'S
NOT, I'M AFRAID, THE CHIEF
CLERK. HE OBVIOUSLY IS NOT
AFRAID OF THE CHIEF CLERK. SO
GOOD FOR HIM. AND THEN YOU KNOW,
POLITICAL COURAGE AS WELL. YOU
KNOW, HE'S WILLING TO STAND UP
TO THE STATUS QUO TO HELP TO
HELP OTHERS. AND AS SENATOR
UMBERG, YOU KNOW, SAID, WHEN I
THINK OF HIM, I DO, I DO THINK
OF CHILDREN, THE LATE SCHOOL
START TIME. EVERYBODY DIDN'T
WANT IT, DIDN'T WANT IT EVEN I
DIDN'T WANT IT IN THE BEGINNING.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA, WE HAVE
SAVED LIVES BECAUSE WE ENDED UP
ULTIMATELY SUPPORTING THE BILL.
NOW, THE FIRST TIME IT CAME UP,
I VOTED NO. AND ONE OF HIS
SPEAKERS WAS, WAS A PROFESSOR
FROM STANFORD. AND THE REASON I
KNOW HE WAS A PROFESSOR FROM
STANFORD BECAUSE HE TOLD US
EIGHT TIMES, HE'S FROM STANFORD.
HE'S NOT FROM HARVARD, HE'S FROM
STANFORD. HE SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE
THAT ANYWAY. AND THAT'S THE ONLY
TIME I'VE EVER WELL, I'VE GOTTEN
FRUSTRATED AT THE AT THE DÍAS,
BUT NEVER MAD. AND I GOT MAD AND
HE BASICALLY CALLED ME STUPID.
AND I SAID I THREW MY BUSINESS
CARD AT HIM AND SAID, HEY, YOU
KNOW, YOU GOT A PROBLEM. YOU
COME AND RUN AGAINST ME. AND
THEN I WENT LATER THAT DAY TO
APOLOGIZE TO ANTHONY AND ANTHONY
TOOK MY SIDE. HE SAID NO, HE WAS
RUDE. YOU HAD EVERY RIGHT TO DO
THAT, WHICH I SO APPRECIATED.
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY I GOT AN
APOLOGY EMAIL FROM THIS
PROFESSOR WHO SPECIALIZES IN
SLEEP AND SAID, THE WAY THAT THE
REASON WHY HE CONDUCTED HIMSELF
SO POORLY IS HE DID NOT HAVE
ENOUGH SLEEP THE NIGHT BEFORE.
YOU CANNOT MAKE THESE THINGS UP.
I AM WRITING A BOOK. I'LL GIVE
YOU ALL A COMPLIMENTARY COPY
WHEN I'M DONE. AND THEN AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY DYSLEXIA SCREENING FOR
K-2. WE ALL KNOW THAT IF YOU ARE
NOT LITERATE BY THE THIRD GRADE,
THAT IS ONE OF THE DATA POINTS
THAT DEMOGRAPHERS USE TO PROJECT
FUTURE PRISON POPULATIONS. 38
STATES HAVE BEEN SCREENING. WE
HAVEN'T BEEN SCREENING. AND SO
THAT COMES IN THE LINE, I
BELIEVE NEXT, NEXT YEAR. AND
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE TO SO MANY PEOPLE AND
SO MANY FAMILIES. AND AGAIN, I
CAN'T THINK OF ANYBODY DURING MY
TIME HERE WHO'S DONE MORE FOR
EDUCATION THAN ANTHONY
PORTANTINO. AND THEN WE HAVE
PHYSICAL COURAGE AS YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE HE'LL TELL YOU HE
REPRESENTS MORE ARMENIANS THAN
ANYBODY OUTSIDE OF ARMENIA. AND
HE HAS BEEN A PHENOMENAL
ADVOCATE FOR THEM. AND HE'S
TAKEN SO MANY TRIPS TO ARMENIA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC OF ARTSAKH.
HE'S BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES
DOWN IN ARTSAKH, WHERE YOU CAN
EASILY GET YOU CAN GET KILLED AT
ANY POINT. AND HE'S HE'S BEEN
THERE ADVOCATING AND I KNOW I
WAS THERE A FEW YEARS AGO AND I
WANTED TO GO TO THE FRONT LINES.
NO ONE ELSE IN MY DELEGATION
WANTED TO GO AND DIDN'T GO. AND
THEN COLLABORATION. I THINK
EVERYBODY KNOWS MY WIFE'S MY
WIFE'S ARMENIAN. AND I'D LIKE TO
SAY I'M ABC ARMENIAN BY CHOICE,
BUT AS AS ARMENIAN AS I AM KNOWN
AS MORE ARMENIAN THAN THAN
ANTHONY. WE'VE WORKED TOGETHER
ON THE BOARD OF THE ARMENIAN
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS FOUNDATION,
WHERE WE'VE RAISED MONEY TO MAKE
THE NEXT GENERATION AWARE OF
GENOCIDE AND THE PERILS OF THAT,
AS WELL AS GIVING OUT
SCHOLARSHIPS, HE CREATED AND
THEN CHAIRS THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON CALIFORNIA, ARMENIA AND
ARTSAKH MUTUAL TRADE, ART AND
CULTURE, WHERE WE PROMOTE TRADE
AND CULTURAL EXCHANGES WITH
ARMENIA AND CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
HE SECURED $1.8 MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR THE FOR THE ARMENIAN
MUSEUM IN GLENDALE, WHICH I
HAVEN'T VISITED YET. BUT WE NEED
TO DO THAT AND THEN GO TO REYES.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW OF ANY OTHER
LEGISLATOR WHO'S DONE DONE MORE
FOR THE ARMENIANS, CALIFORNIA
ARMENIANS THAN YOU. ANTHONY AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT, AS
DOES MY FAMILY. AND THEN
KINDNESS. HE'S HE'S SO KIND.
JUST TODAY HE GIVES ME A PIECE
OF MEATLOAF. MEATLOAF SANDWICH.
AND YOU'RE THINKING, WELL, I GOT
ONE TOO. SO WHAT? BUT THEN I
HADN'T HAD BREAKFAST, SO I ATE
IT AND THEN I RAN INTO HIM LATER
AND HE'S LIKE, WHAT HAVE YOU
HAD? I GO, I DID HAVE. HE GOES,
DID YOU HAVE IT HOT? HE SAID,
NO, I HAD IT COLD AND IT WAS
EXCELLENT. HE GOES, WELL, YOU
GOT TO HAVE ONE HOT HERE. SO I
GOT TWO. SO I GOT ONE SITTING IN
MY REFRIGERATOR. SO YOU WANT TO
SHARE THAT LATER. YOU CAN BUT
BUT JUST A SAMPLE OF BEING KIND
I HAD A CONSTITUENT. HE WAS 20
YEARS OLD WHEN I MET HIM. HIM
AND HIS DAD CAME TO VISIT ME
WHEN HE WAS 18.5. HE GOT T-BONED
BY A DRUNK DRIVER AND HE
SUFFERED BRAIN INJURY. MOST
DATES YOU GET, YOU CAN GET
GOVERNMENT SERVICES UP TO THE
AGE OF 22. IN CALIFORNIA, IT'S
ONLY 18. I TRIED, I TRIED FOR
FOUR YEARS TO GET THAT AND
COULDN'T GET REALLY VERY FAR
WITH IT. AND HE CAME TO ME
KNOWING HOW IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE
IS, HE SAID, I'M GOING TO TAKE
IT ON. HE GOT IT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. ALTHOUGH HE DIDN'T
GET THE GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE ON
IT. BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT. AND IT GAVE GAVE HOPE TO
THIS FAMILY. AND I'M HOPING AT
SOME POINT SOMEBODY TAKES THAT
BATON UP AND FINISHES IT. AND
THEN HE'S JUST BEEN VERY, VERY
KIND TO MY FAMILY. WE WERE AT A
I DON'T KNOW IF I GET IN TROUBLE
FOR THIS, BUT I WAS AT AN SEIU
BOX AT SANTA ANITA RACETRACK.
AND ANTHONY WAS THERE, WAS THERE
WITH MY WIFE AND WITH MY MOTHER
IN LAW, WHO AT THAT TIME, I
THINK WAS 93. AND WE'RE HAVING A
GREAT TIME. AND THEN ANTHONY
EXCUSES HIMSELF, LEAVES AND THEN
HE COMES BACK. I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE CALLED. A
TRUMPETER, THE GUY THAT BLOWS
THE HORN. SO HE BRINGS UP A
TRUMPETER. AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
HE KNEW THIS, BUT THE TRUMPETER
KNOWS HOW TO PLAY THE ARMENIAN
NATIONAL ANTHEM. SO HE'S IN HER
BOX PLAYING THE ARMENIAN
NATIONAL ANTHEM. TO MY TO MY
MOTHER IN LAW, WHO LOVED IT,
WHO? WE GET THE ARMENIAN
NEWSPAPER. SO SHE FOLLOWS
ANTHONY ALL THE TIME IN THE IN
THE ARMENIAN NEWSPAPERS. AND HE
KIDDINGLY SAID, I HOPE YOU'RE
NOT SERIOUS, THAT YOU'RE HER
FAVORITE SENATOR, BUT YOU'RE
DEFINITELY HER SECOND FAVORITE
SENATOR. WITH THAT, I GOT TO
HAVE IMMENSE AMOUNT OF RESPECT
FOR YOU. YOU HAVE NOT SHARED
WHAT YOU'RE DOING NEXT. LOOKING
FORWARD, LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT. I KNOW EVERY PERSON THAT I
KNOW THAT LIVES IN YOUR DISTRICT
ACTUALLY KNOWS YOU, BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYBODY WHO
WORKS THEIR DISTRICT HARDER THAN
YOU. AND I LOVE YOUR HEART. I
LOVE YOUR PERSEVERANCE, AND I
REALLY WISH YOU THE BEST MOVING
FORWARD. AND WITH THAT, IF YOU
COULD ALL STAND AND GIVE A NICE
SENATE CONGRATULATORY CLAP FOR
SENATOR PORTENTINO.
THANK YOU. SO SORRY ABOUT THAT.
WELL, IT'S GOING TO BREAK MY
HEART TO RAISE HAMBURG'S RENT
NEXT YEAR. AFTER HIS KIND WORDS,
AS I SAID DURING OUR OUR DINNER,
I LOVE WHAT WE GET TO DO. WE GET
TO HELP PEOPLE. BUT I HATE THE
POMP AND CIRCUMSTANCE OF THIS
LIFESTYLE. AND SO THIS IS
DIFFICULT FOR ME, BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, TO TALK. I DO WANT TO GIVE
A BIG SHOUT OUT TO MY STAFF.
WHO'S HERE? THANK YOU. LET'S
GIVE OUR STAFFS, ALL OF OUR
STAFFS, A BIG ROUND OF APPLAUSE
BECAUSE. WE COULD NOT DO THIS
JOB WITHOUT THEM BOTH IN THE
DISTRICT AND HERE. AND I HAVE
THE BEST DISTRICT AND THE BEST
STAFF. AND SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO OUR DISTRICT. AND
AS IT'S BEEN SAID, I LOVE MY
FAMILY, I HAVE TWO FANTASTIC
DAUGHTERS. A DECADE APART. AND
YOU DO THIS BECAUSE YOU CARE
ABOUT THE NEXT GENERATION,
RIGHT? THAT'S NOT WHY WE DO
THIS. AND I HAVE TO GIVE A BIG
SHOUT OUT TO MY WONDERFUL
SPOUSE, ELLEN, WHO PUTS UP WITH
ME. YOU ALL GET ME HERE. SHE
GETS ME AT HOME AND SHE DOESN'T
HAVE TO PUT UP WITH ME. I DON'T
HAVE A VOTE AT HOME AND SO SHE
HAS TO PUT UP WITH ME, EVEN
THOUGH I DON'T HAVE A VOTE. AND
SO I COULD NOT FUNCTION WITHOUT
THE GREAT SUPPORT THAT I HAVE AT
HOME. MR. WILK, YOU ARE A GOOD
FRIEND AND LATER I'LL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT YOU, BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
KIND WORDS AND INTRODUCING ME TO
YOUR FAMILY AND SHARING A LOVE
OF ARMENIA AND MR. UMBERGER HAS
BEEN A PLEASURE LIVING WITH YOU
FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS. WE SIT
THERE AND WE JUST I USED TO SAY,
EAT MEATLOAF, BUT NOW I FOUND
OUT YOU DON'T LIKE MY MEATLOAF.
SO I SAVED TWO SLICES IN THE
FRIDGE SO YOU'D HAVE ONE. SO NOW
I HAVE AN EXTRA SLICE OF
MEATLOAF. I'LL HAVE TO GIVE IT
TO THE PRO TEM EMERITUS WHO
LOVES MY MEATLOAF, BUT, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN'T GET ANYTHING
THROUGH THE SYSTEM WITHOUT, YOU
KNOW, IN THIS HOUSE, 21 VOTES
AND 41 VOTES IN THE OTHER HOUSE.
SO BY NATURE, WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH EACH OTHER. WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT EACH OTHER. WE HAVE TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY. AND IT'S
BEEN AN HONOR OF A LIFETIME TO
SERVE IN THIS CHAMBER. AND I
REMEMBER MY FIRST VISIT TO THE
CAPITOL WHEN I WAS A FLEDGLING
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN 2000, 24
YEARS AGO, JUST BEING BLOWN AWAY
BY THE MAJESTY OF THIS PLACE, BY
THE IMPORT OF WHAT WE GET TO DO
AFFECTING PEOPLE'S LIVES AND HOW
THEY CONDUCT THEMSELVES AND WHAT
THEY LEARN AND HOW MUCH THEY GET
TO SLEEP. AND WE GET TO TALK
ABOUT VALUES AND LEGISLATE AND,
AND JUST BE A POSITIVE INFLUENCE
ON PEOPLE. AND ONE OF THE MOTTOS
THAT I'VE ALWAYS TRIED TO BE IS
BE AN OPTIMIST. AND I ALWAYS
SAY, IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE
TOMORROW IS GOING TO BE BETTER
THAN TODAY, YOU DON'T GET OUT OF
BED. AND SO WE HAVE TO BELIEVE
THAT TOMORROW IS GOING TO BE
BETTER THAN TODAY, AND WE GET TO
WORK ON THAT. THAT'S THE JOB WE
GET TO DO, IS WE GET TO MAKE
TOMORROW BETTER THAN TODAY, AND
WE DO THAT MANY TIMES ACROSS THE
AISLE. AND I'M GLAD SENATOR
DASCHLE AND SENATOR WILK TALKED
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF INNER
PARTY COLLABORATION, BECAUSE IT
MAKES US BETTER WHEN WE HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION, WHEN WE COME
TOGETHER AND WE DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU FOR
LETTING TO MY CONSTITUENTS AND
THE FOLKS WHO SENT ME HERE A
DEEP APPRECIATION FOR THIS HONOR
OF A LIFETIME TO SERVE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND IN PARTICULAR,
TO SERVE IN THIS HOUSE WITH, YOU
KNOW, FOR SENATOR ATKINS. AND I
CAME IN TOGETHER AND WE'VE KNOWN
EACH OTHER PROBABLY FOR 40
YEARS. AND IT'S JUST BEEN AN
HONOR TO HAVE SERVED WITH YOU
AND TO SERVE IN THIS BODY. AND I
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU AND JUST BE PART OF
THIS WONDERFUL WORLD. SO THANK
YOU.
NEXT. NEXT UP, WE'RE GOING TO BE
RECOGNIZING THE SENATOR
REPRESENTING DISTRICT 35.
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR ATKINS
IS GOING TO KICK US OFF WITH THE
FIRST REMARKS. WELL, THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. SO LET
ME JUST START WITH A REALLY
PERSONAL THING. AND SAY,
SENATOR, IT HAS BEEN WONDERFUL
TO SERVE THESE LAST 14 YEARS
WITH YOU. YOU GOT HERE A LITTLE
BIT BEFORE, MAYBE SIX MONTHS
BEFORE IN A SPECIAL. BUT I WAS
HAPPY TO GET HERE AND HAVE YOU
AS ONE OF THE FOLKS TO HELP ME
GET ACCLIMATED. IT'S AN HONOR,
COLLEAGUES TO RISE IN SUPPORT
AND HONOR SOMEONE WHO'S
DEDICATED HIS CAREER TO SERVING
THE PEOPLE OF HIS COMMUNITY FOR
MORE THAN TWO DECADES. FIRST, AS
A GARDENA CITY COUNCIL MEMBER,
THEN AS A STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
AND NOW AS A MEMBER OF OUR BODY
HERE IN THE SENATE. SENATOR
BRADFORD HAS ALWAYS BEEN SPARKED
BY THE DESIRE TO FIGHT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE TOO OFTEN IGNORED OR
DISCOUNTED. YOU KNOW, THAT MIGHT
SEEM LIKE A FAMILIAR THEME TO
MANY OF US, BUT THAT'S A
REFLECTION OF THE DIVERSITY OF
THIS BODY THAT NOW EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LEGISLATURE,
SENATOR BRADFORD HAS PROMOTED
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES AND
INCREASED INCLUSION. HIS
ILLUSTRIOUS SERVICE INCLUDES
CHAIRING THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS, THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY,
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS,
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY, AND CHAIRING THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
STATUS OF BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
GROUNDBREAKING POLICE REFORM,
POLICE DECERTIFICATION.
PROTECTING THE HISTORIC
COMMUNITY OF ALLENSWORTH.
RETURNING BRUCE'S BEACH, PART OF
THE REPARATIONS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT NOW, NO MATTER HOW HARD
THE WORK OR LATE THE HOUR, AS WE
WILL SEE AGAIN AT THE END OF
THIS SESSION, HE HAS ALWAYS
LOOKED QUITE DAPPER DOING IT. TO
THIS DAY, WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW MANY PAIRS OF
WONDERFUL SHOES DOES HE ACTUALLY
OWN? PHªN ASIDE, A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO I HAD THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF APPOINTING
MEMBERS TO THE TASK FORCE TO
STUDY AND DEVELOP REPARATIONS
PROPOSALS FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS.
SENATOR BRADFORD, WITH HIS LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND HIS CAREER SPENT
IN PUBLIC SERVICE, WAS THE
PERFECT CHOICE TO DO THIS
IMPORTANT WORK. IT IS HISTORIC
AND MANY WILL LOOK AT THIS WORK
AND USE IT AS AN EXAMPLE. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD, WE ARE MAKING
HISTORY. THANK YOU SENATOR. HE'S
NEVER ONE TO SHY AWAY FROM TOUGH
ISSUES WHEN HE ATTACHES HIS NAME
TO SOMETHING, YOU PRETTY MUCH
ARE ASSURED THAT HE'LL GET IT
DONE. I NAMED 1 OR 2 THINGS, BUT
LET ME ALSO TALK ABOUT NAME AND
LIKENESS. NCAA SPORTS WITH THE
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY. AGAIN I'M
GOING TO REPEAT BECAUSE IT BEARS
REPEATING BRUCE'S BEACH, THE
EBONY ALERT, SO MANY, SO MANY
THINGS. AS A SACRAMENTO OBSERVER
ONCE WROTE, THERE IS JUST NO
QUIT TO HIM. MANY OF OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SAY,
THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR YOUR
DEDICATION AND THE FACT THAT YOU
DON'T QUIT. YOU WON'T GIVE UP
UNTIL YOU GET IT DONE. ANOTHER
MORE FUN FACT AS A FORMER
NIGHTCLUB PRODUCER, HE WENT ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ANNUAL
JAZZ FEST IN GARDENA IS A HIT.
AND IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN THERE
AND HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPERIENCE IT, NAMED WONDERFUL
ARTIST, YOU SHOULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT. IT IS COMING
UP, BY THE WAY, AT THE END OF
AUGUST, A FRIEND TO EVERYONE,
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT ALIKE. I
WILL NEVER FORGET WHEN HE ASKED
ME AS PRO TEM TO INVITE THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM CERES TO THE PRO
TEM CUP, AND I THOUGHT, HOW AM I
GOING TO EXPLAIN TO THIS,
SENATOR THAT THIS IS A
DEMOCRATIC FUNDRAISER? BUT YES,
WE SHOULD PROBABLY CONSIDER
THAT. AND I LEFT IT AT THAT. BUT
HE THOUGHT IT WAS A GREAT IDEA.
AND MAYBE IF WE WOULD DO THOSE
THINGS TOGETHER MORE OFTEN, YOU
KNOW, IT WOULD BE A GOOD THING.
BUT I JUST LOOKED HE, YOU KNOW,
WHEN HE IS A FRIEND, HE IS A
FRIEND, LOYAL TO THE END, TO THE
PERSON THAT HE CALLS A FRIEND.
AND AGAIN, DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN, SOME OF MY FONDEST
MEMORIES ARE GOING TO BE OF
SHARED TIMES, PARTICULARLY AS I
CAME IN. AS I SAID EARLIER TO
THE ASSEMBLY AND HAD YOU TO LOOK
TO, I WILL AND HAVE FORGIVEN YOU
FOR TELLING ME THAT YOUR
FAVORITE LESBIAN WAS THE WOMAN
FROM STOCKTON. I'M RIGHT HERE,
SENATOR. I'M RIGHT HERE. I'M
RIGHT HERE, SENATOR. I'M RIGHT
HERE. SEE, I JUST GOT YOU IN
TROUBLE. BUT AGAIN, THE FONDEST
MEMORIES, THE FONDEST MEMORIES
OF FUN TIMES, OF SERIOUS TIMES,
BUT OF SERVICE, OF SERVICE TO
THE PEOPLE IN YOUR COMMUNITY AND
THE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE SPECIAL ROLE THAT YOU PLAY
AND THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PLAY TO PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AS WE TACKLE HISTORIC,
INTERNALIZED RACISM AND TRY TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THIS
CULTURE. THAT IS WHAT I WILL
REMEMBER MOST ABOUT THE WORK
THAT YOU HAVE DONE. COLLEAGUES,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ACKNOWLEDGING
SENATOR BRADFORD.
I HAVE TO BE THE BAD ONE UP
HERE. COLLEAGUES, IF WE CAN HOLD
OUR APPLAUSE UNTIL THE MEMBER IS
DONE SPEAKING, AND IF WE COULD
KINDLY KEEP TO THE TWO MINUTE
REMARKS. PRETTY PLEASE. OUR NEXT
SPEAKER IS SENATOR DALI. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS.
GOSH, I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS.
SO FIRST I WANT TO JUST SAY THAT
I DID THE SAME THING. I WENT
BACK THROUGH MY TEXT MESSAGES
AND I WILL JUST SAY THAT SENATOR
BRADFORD HAS NEVER MISSED A
FATHER'S DAY OR MY BIRTHDAY,
ALWAYS TEXTING ME. BUT THE CRAZY
THING IS, IS HE HAS A
BLACKBERRY, SO HE DOESN'T ALWAYS
COMMUTE WITH WHEN I'M SENDING
HIM TEXTS. OR MAYBE HE JUST
DOESN'T WANT IT TO WORK, BUT I
WANT TO GO BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY.
AND I THINK IT WAS REALLY
AWESOME THAT SENATOR ATKINS
BROUGHT UP STEVE AND HIS SHOES.
SO I CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY. STEVE
IS THE MOST BEST DRESSED
LEGISLATOR THERE IS, AND HE
REALLY DOES HAVE A LOT OF SHOES.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I'M A FARMER
AND I STRUGGLE IN THIS AREA, BUT
I INTRODUCED MY DAUGHTER WAS
HERE, SHE WAS 4 OR 5, AND I
INTRODUCED MY DAUGHTER TO STEVE
AND SHE'S LOOKING AT HIM AND
HE'S GOT THESE REALLY AWESOME
SHOES ON. AND SHE'S KIND OF
LOOKING HIM UP AND DOWN. AND HE
SAYS, WHAT AIN'T YOU NEVER SEEN
A BLACK MAN BEFORE? AND I WAS
LIKE, OH MY GOSH, RIGHT. SO AND
SHE'S LIKE, I REALLY LIKE YOUR
SHOES. AND SHE SAID, THEY'RE
REALLY NICE WHITE SHOES. AND HE
SAYS, THOSE AREN'T WHITE. THOSE
ARE BONE. AND SO IT STARTED OFF
THEIR RELATIONSHIP. SO I WANT TO
SPEAK ABOUT THAT FOR JUST A
MINUTE BEFORE I GET INTO THE
SERIOUSNESS OF IT. SO ROSALIND
AND STEVE GO BACK AND FORTH ALL
THE TIME. AND SO, FAST FORWARD A
FEW YEARS, I WAS RUNNING FOR THE
SENATE. WE HAD A WATCH PARTY
HERE IN TOWN. IT WAS A SPECIAL.
SO NOBODY WAS HERE. BUT STEVE
WAS AROUND, AND SO WE INVITED
HIM TO COME TO THE WATCH PARTY.
SO WE WERE TO WE WERE AT THIS
PLACE, AND ROSALIND AND STEVE
ARE GOING BACK AND FORTH, AND
SHE'S DOING CARTWHEELS AND SHE'S
LIKE, HEY, STEVE, CAN YOU DO A
CARTWHEEL? AND STEVE'S OF COURSE
I CAN. SO STEVE DID A CARTWHEEL
AND UNFORTUNATELY HE LANDED ON
HIS TOE AND I'M NOT SURE IF IT
WAS BROKEN OR NOT, BUT HE SAID
IT WASN'T. BUT HE LIMPED AROUND
FOR NEARLY TWO WEEKS, AND HE
SAID TO ME, BRIAN, HE SAYS EVERY
TIME I STEP, I SEE THAT LITTLE
ROUND FACE OF ROSALIND SAYING,
STEVE, CAN YOU DO A CARTWHEEL?
SO STEVE, YOU'VE BEEN PART OF
OUR LIFE AND MY FAMILY'S. I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND WHEN I DID
GET HER A BICYCLE, I WAS VERY
SURE TO LET HER KNOW THE LAWS
THAT YOU PASSED, BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE BEEN RAN
OVER ON A BICYCLE LIKE THREE
TIMES. TWICE. OKAY, TWICE. AND
I'M GLAD YOU PASSED THOSE LAWS
TO KEEP MY DAUGHTER SAFE, WITH
THAT BEING SAID, I WAS HIS
SEATMATE IN THE ASSEMBLY, AND I.
SCOTT WELCOME TO THE TO THE ODD
COUPLE. I SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY. GOT THE ODD COUPLE
THERE, AND I GOT STEVE. I REALLY
ENJOYED OUR TIME AS SEATMATES
TOGETHER, BUT I WANT TO NOW TALK
ABOUT WHAT I REALLY THINK. STEVE
HAS ADDED TO, AT LEAST FOR ME,
BEING YOUR VICE CHAIR OF ENERGY.
STEVE, I CAN'T TELL YOU YOUR
KNOWLEDGE, YOUR HISTORY OF THE
OF WHAT HAPPENED. AND WE WENT
THROUGH BANKRUPTCIES, WILDFIRE,
POWER OUTAGES AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THAT SPACE, I
THINK IS SORELY GOING TO BE IS
GOING TO BE MISSED. THERE'S NO
WAY, PEOPLE HAVE THE DEPTH OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU HAVE IN THAT
SPACE. AND I WANT TO SAY, AS
YOUR VICE CHAIR, I'M REALLY
APPRECIATED WORKING ALONGSIDE
YOU. NOW, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE OTHER THINGS I THINK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT AS A REPUBLICAN,
THAT STEVE HAS REALLY BROUGHT
FORTH, I THINK, AND SENATOR
ATKINS TOUCHED ON IT AND HIS
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO TEACH WHAT
HAS NOT BEEN TAUGHT IN THE BLACK
CULTURE AND WHAT THEIR
ACHIEVEMENTS ARE. THERE ISN'T
NOT HAS NOT BEEN TAUGHT IN OUR
SCHOOLS. AND STEVE HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION IN THAT AREA. YOU KNOW,
I THOUGHT BACK ABOUT THE MOVIE,
THAT IT WAS OUT. IT'S THE IT'S
THE MOVIE ABOUT THE HIDDEN
FIGURES. AND THAT WAS BASICALLY
WHERE IBM WAS TAKEN OVER THE
JOBS FOR THE SPACE EXPLORATION,
AND IT WAS BLACK PEOPLE THAT
REALLY WERE DOING THE WORK AND
THEY COULDN'T. AND IT'S A GREAT
MOVIE. BUT BASICALLY, STEVE, YOU
BROUGHT SO MANY OF THOSE OTHER
ISSUES WHERE WE HAVEN'T BEEN
EDUCATED. AND I THINK THAT
YOU'VE DONE SUCH A SERVICE FOR
CALIFORNIA, AND ESPECIALLY I
THINK, FOR FOLKS LIKE ME WHO
DIDN'T GET THAT CULTURE AND KNOW
IT. SO I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU.
AND I THINK CALIFORNIA IS A
BETTER PLACE BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW, THE
ADVANCES THAT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY DIDN'T GET CREDIT FOR,
THAT REALLY HAS CHANGED
CALIFORNIA AND AMERICA. SO I
WANT TO SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, I'VE
HAD A LOT OF LEGISLATORS IN MY
DISTRICT, THE BLACK CAUCUS CAME
TO TAHOE WITH ME. AND STEVE HAS
NEVER BEEN TO MY DISTRICT. OUT
OF ALL THE LEGISLATORS, STEVE
HAS NEVER BEEN TO MY DISTRICT.
YOU'VE BEEN TO TAHOE, BUT NOT
WITH ME. SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
YOU'VE BEEN A GREAT FRIEND. YOU
HAVE BRIDGED THE GAP BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS. YOU
ALWAYS COME OUT AND I REALLY
ENJOYED OUR TIME. EVERY NIGHT.
STEVE AND I HUNG OUT AROUND THIS
TOWN GETTING TO KNOW EACH OTHER.
YOU'VE BEEN A CHAMPION. YOU'VE
BEEN SOMEBODY WHO'S SHOWN THAT
WORK ACROSS THE AISLE, AND HARD
WORK REALLY MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
AND SO I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
YOU'RE INVITED TO THE RANCH.
I'LL TAKE YOU FISHING. I'LL KEEP
YOU SAFE. IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE UP
THERE. I LOVE YOU, MAN. YOU'VE
BEEN AWESOME AND A GREAT FRIEND.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR BRADFORD. WELL, I'M
REALLY AT A LOSS FOR WORDS, BUT
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU WHO I
HAVE HAD THE HONOR TO SERVE WITH
OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS. THIS
HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY, AND I'M GLAD I'M
NOT CRYING LIKE I DID TEN YEARS
AGO. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY ON OUR LAST DAY
AND THEY HIT THE MEMBERS
TRIBUTE, I WAS LITERALLY CRYING
LIKE A BABY. I MEAN, TEARS WERE
JUST RUNNING DOWN MY FACE. SO
MUCH SO THAT A LOBBYIST THAT WAS
SITTING UP IN THE BALCONY TEXTED
AND SAID, GARDENA, BECAUSE I WAS
JUST. THAT'S HOW HE REFERRED TO
ME. GARDENA SAYS, GARDENA.
YOU'RE CRYING LIKE A BABY. I
SAYS, WELL, BUT THIS PLACE HAS A
REALLY SPECIAL PLACE IN MY HEART.
I'VE HAD MANY JOBS, MANY
DIFFERENT CAREERS, BUT THIS IS
TRULY THE BEST CAREER AND JOB
I'VE EVER HAD. I'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
PROBABLY OVER 200 INDIVIDUALS
FROM ALL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO I'VE LEARNED SO
MUCH FROM, ESPECIALLY, LIKE I
SAY, MY FRIENDS FROM THE FARMING
COMMUNITY, WHEN I CAME FROM THE
URBAN AREA BELIEVING THAT I KNEW
ABOUT THE FOREST AND ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT I HAD BEEN TAUGHT AS
AN URBAN PERSON, NOT UNTIL I
TOOK A TRIP UP THERE THAT I
LEARNED FIRSTHAND THAT WHAT WE
WERE BEING TOLD IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE TRUTH, AND
SEEING IT FIRSTHAND, BEING ABLE
TO EXPERIENCE THAT. SO I WANT TO
THANK THOSE WHO HAVE SHARED
THEIR DISTRICT WITH ME AND KNOW
I HAVE YET TO BE THE GO TO
BEAVER, BUT I PROMISE I WILL GET
THERE AT SOME POINT, AND MAKE
SURE I SEE FIRSTHAND WHAT YOU DO
AND WHAT YOU CONTINUE TO DO
BECAUSE YOU'RE A PASSIONATE
FARMER. YOU BELIEVE IN WHAT YOU
DO, AND I THANK YOU, BRIAN DALLY
AND YOUR FAMILY FOR YOUR
FRIENDSHIP OVER THE LAST 12
YEARS TO, PRO TEM EMERITUS
ATKINS, WE HAVE SERVED BOTH IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
TOGETHER. AND YOU HAVE TRULY
BEEN A TREMENDOUS FRIEND, BUT AN
AMAZING LEADER. SO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND BELIEVING
IN ME AND APPOINTING ME TO THE
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE. IT GAVE
ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT MYSELF AND MY CULTURE. I
LEARNED SO MUCH ON THAT
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE OF THINGS
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT I
WOULD HAVE KNOWN, BUT I DIDN'T.
AND I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK ON THAT LEGISLATION AND
SO MUCH MORE. THAT HAS IMPACTED
CALIFORNIANS IN THE NATION AND
AGAIN, I'M GOING TO MISS THIS
PLACE, BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
FORGET ANY OF YOU BECAUSE YOU
ALL HAVE TOUCHED ME IN A VERY
SPECIAL WAY. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR BEING MY
FRIEND, BEING MY COLLEAGUE, AND
WE'RE NOT ALWAYS AGREE ON THINGS,
BUT HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION, HAVING
DIALOG, BEING ADULTS IN THE
ROOM. AND THAT'S WHAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE. AND I HAVE A GOOD
HAVE A STORY ABOUT EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU, BECAUSE WE'VE
BONDED IN SOME SPECIAL WAY
DURING THE EIGHT YEARS OR THE 14
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE, WHICH PRETTY MUCH
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU. AND
AGAIN, IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO
SERVE. AND I JUST LOOK FORWARD
TO THE FUTURE, AND I HOPE OUR
FRIENDSHIPS WILL LAST BEYOND MY
TIME IN THE STATE SENATE. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD, FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
RECOGNIZING THE SENATOR FROM
DISTRICT 37. SENATOR MIN.
SENATOR UMBERG WILL SENATOR
UMBER WILL BEGIN WITH HIS
REMARKS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES, I'M
PROUD TO HAVE THE DISTINCT HONOR
TO RECOGNIZE AND HONOR THE
SERVICE OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY. I FIRST MET
SENATOR MIN IN 2018. HE PROBABLY
DOESN'T REMEMBER IT. THE ORANGE
COUNTY REGISTRAR'S OFFICE, WHEN
WE WERE BOTH BASICALLY FILING
OUR OUR PAPERS TO RUN FOR OFFICE,
SENATOR MIN THEN WAS A PROFESSOR
AT UCI, AND THE VOTERS IN THAT
ELECTION, MUCH LIKE SEVERAL OF
MY ELECTIONS, THOUGHT HE SHOULD
CONTINUE HIS SERVICE AS A
PROFESSOR AT UCI, AT LEAST FOR A
LITTLE WHILE. BUT WE HAD LUNCH
SHORTLY AFTER THAT ELECTION, AND
I RECOGNIZED HIS DETERMINATION,
HIS PASSION, HIS INTELLECT, HIS
DEDICATION TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND
SAID, YOU KNOW, YOU OUGHT TO
THINK ABOUT COMING TO THE
LEGISLATURE. YOU OUGHT TO COME
UP HERE AND MAKE POLICY WITH US,
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'D BE A VERY
VALUABLE ASSET. AND INDEED, OF
COURSE, YOU HAVE BEEN. AND IT
WAS A TWO FOR ONE DEAL, BECAUSE
ALONG WITH DAVE, WE GOT JANE.
JANE IS A TENURED PROFESSOR AT
UCI, AND I THINK RESPONSIBLE FOR
AT LEAST ASSISTING WITH EIGHT
PIECES OF LEGISLATION AND SHE'S
BEEN A VALUABLE ASSET AS WELL.
NOW, I KNOW DAVE, HIS SERVICE IS
GOING TO CONTINUE. HE'S GOING TO
HAVE A LITTLE LONGER COMMUTE. I
THINK NEXT YEAR THAN THAN THIS
YEAR. BUT I'M CONFIDENT THAT HIS
SERVICE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS,
ESPECIALLY TO THOSE OF US IN
ORANGE COUNTY, ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE, DAVE, I'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO MEET AND INTERACT WITH
HIS WONDERFUL FAMILY AND KIDS
TEDDY, EMMY AND PAXTON. THEY
ARE. THAT'S A TRITE PHRASE, BUT
BUT THEY ARE REALLY THE APPLE OF
HIS EYE. HE AND JANE DO SUCH A
WONDERFUL JOB AS PARENTS AND
BALANCING SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS AT THE SAME TIME. DAVE
HAS SERVED AS THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE AAPI LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
HE'S PLAYED A MAJOR, MAJOR ROLE
IN SECURING PASSAGE OF THE AAPI
EQUITY BUDGET IN 2021. THIS IS A
MONUMENTAL INVESTMENT THAT
BENEFITED NOT JUST THE AAPI
COMMUNITY, BUT BUT ALL OF US IN
CALIFORNIA, DAVE NEVER LOST
SIGHT OF WHERE HE CAME FROM.
HE'S THE SON OF IMMIGRANT
PARENTS, AND HE'S THE ONLY
KOREAN-AMERICAN HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND HE NEVER LOST
SIGHT OF THE FACT THAT HE HAS A
DUTY. AND RESPONSIBILITY TO
ORANGE COUNTY, BRINGING $80
MILLION IN DIRECT FUNDING FOR A
NUMBER OF PROJECTS ALL AROUND
ORANGE COUNTY IN PARTICULAR, TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY IN IRVINE,
TUSTIN, COSTA MESA, NEWPORT
BEACH AND LAGUNA BEACH, AND
DIRECTING FUNDING TO THE ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY AND
WILDFIRE PREVENTION PROGRAM.
HE'S BEEN A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR
GUN SAFETY. THOSE AT THE ORANGE
COUNTY FAIR WILL ATTEST TO THAT.
SENATOR MIN, HE'S BEEN A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY,
INCLUDING BANNING GUN SHOWS AT
THE ORANGE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS,
DAVE IS A PRODUCT OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION, HAS BEEN DEDICATED
AND DEVOTED TO PUBLIC EDUCATION.
DURING HIS TIME HERE, HE SERVED
AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
AND TOOK A NUMBER OF COURAGEOUS
STEPS TO PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT.
IMPORTANTLY, I HAD FIRSTHAND
SORT OF A FRONT ROW SEAT TO
WATCH HIM DURING THE OIL SPILL
IN HUNTINGTON BEACH, WHICH
OCCURRED A FEW YEARS AGO, WHERE
DAVE WAS ON SITE IMMEDIATELY.
AND THEN HE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO ASSIST AND BAN
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING, WHICH
IMPACTED OUR WILDLIFE, OUR SEA
LIFE, OUR COASTLINE IN ORANGE
COUNTY, WE WISH DAVE THE BEST OF
LUCK IN HIS FUTURE ENDEAVORS. I
HAVE GREAT, GREAT CONFIDENCE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE DAVE FOR
MANY, MANY, MANY YEARS. AND SO
THANK YOU, DAVE, FOR YOUR
SERVICE HERE. WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BECKER,
YOU'RE UP. WELL THANK YOU. I'M
EXCITED TO DO MY ROAST. I MEAN,
TRIBUTE OF SENATOR MIN, WHO HAS
SERVED THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH GREAT DISTINCTION. AND NOW
WE ALL KNOW DAVE IS THE
BRILLIANT LAW PROFESSOR TURNED
POLICYMAKER. MEN WHO CAN QUOTE
MORTGAGE POLICY LIKE MANY OF US,
CAN RECITE THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. BUT WHAT YOU MAY NOT
KNOW IS THAT HE'S AN EAGLE
SCOUT, A DEDICATED CROSSWORD
AFICIONADO. AND AS WE ALL FOUND
OUT LAST WEEK, A PROUD CAT DAD
AS WELL. IF YOU NEED HELP WITH
WORDLE, HE'S YOUR GUY. AND LET'S
NOT FORGET HIS IMPRESSIVE
TELEVISION RESUME AS WELL. HE'S
REGULARLY BEEN ON CNBC, WHERE HE
TALKED SO ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE
ECONOMY THAT EVEN THE HOSTS
SOMETIMES FORGET THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO ASK QUESTIONS. OF
COURSE, HIS JOURNEY OF PUBLIC
SERVICE WAS ANYTHING BUT
CONVENTIONAL. HE'S THE ONLY
SENATOR I KNOW WHO TOOK AN AN
IMPROV CLASS BEFORE HE RAN FOR
OFFICE. AND IN HINDSIGHT, THAT
WAS THAT WAS PURE GENIUS. ON A
FUN NOTE, SOME OF YOU KNOW, I
SOMETIMES PLAY MUSIC AND I'LL
ASK PEOPLE FOR A SONG, AND I ASK
DAVE WHEN WE FIRST JUST WHEN WE
FIRST MET AND HE PICKED AN
OBSCURE BAND THAT I JUST
HAPPENED TO BE INTO AT THAT
MOMENT, AND WE'VE BEEN BONDED
EVER SINCE. OF COURSE, DAVE'S
STORY IS ONE OF DEEP ROOTS AND
VERY PROUD HERITAGE. HE'S
RELATED TO NONE OTHER THAN QUEEN
MIN. THE LAST QUEEN OF KOREA,
AND I'M SURE SHE'D BE INCREDIBLY
PROUD OF HOW FAR HER DESCENDANT
HAS COME. DAVE HAS FOUGHT
TIRELESSLY TO MAKE THE AMERICAN
DREAM ACCESSIBLE TO ALL, TALKING
AND REALLY DRAWING INSPIRATION
FROM THE STORY OF HIS PARENTS
WHO CAME TO THIS COUNTRY WITH
LITTLE MORE THAN HOPE. AND I
DON'T THINK YOU EVER THOUGHT
THAT YOU WOULD REACH THIS DAY.
AND THEY NEVER THOUGHT THAT THEY
WOULD, THAT THEIR CHILD WOULD
REACH THIS DAY. AND FOR DAVE,
IT'S ALL ABOUT SERVICE. HE'S
BEEN A TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR
ECONOMIC FAIRNESS, ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION, PUBLIC SAFETY AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
JUST MENTIONED, GROUNDBREAKING
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT OUR
COASTLINES FROM OFFSHORE
DRILLING SO THAT FUTURE
GENERATIONS CAN BENEFIT FROM THE
BEAUTY OF OUR BEACHES WITHOUT
THE THREAT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER. AND THAT'S ONE THING I
WANT TO SAY, DAVE. HE NEVER
SHIES AWAY FROM A FIGHT, NEVER
SHIES AWAY FROM A FIGHT. HE'S
CHAMPIONED INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY IN OUR STATE'S
HOUSING MARKET, MAKING IT EASIER
FOR FAMILIES TO ACHIEVE THE
DREAM OF HOMEOWNERSHIP. HE
WORKED TO STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIA'S GUN SAFETY LAWS,
AND IN THE FACE OF THE PANDEMIC,
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN SECURING
VITAL RESOURCES FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES IN ORANGE COUNTY AND
ACROSS THE STATE. HIS EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE ARE A
TESTAMENT TO HIS BELIEF THAT WE
RESPONSIBILITY TO LEAVE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN, AND
AGAIN, I WANT TO SAY, EVEN
THOUGH HE'S HAD A LOT GOING ON,
HE KNOWS EVERY BILL MORE, MUCH
MORE DETAIL THAN I DO. I'M
ALWAYS AMAZED HE'S IN EVERY BILL
THAT COMES UP. HE'S THINKING
ABOUT IT, HE'S WORKING ON IT. HE
HAS AN OPINION ON IT, AND I HAVE
NO DOUBT THAT HE WILL CONTINUE
TO CHAMPION THESE ISSUES WITH
THE SAME PASSION, INTELLIGENCE
AND HUMOR THAT HE'S BROUGHT TO
THE STATE SENATE. DAVE YOU'VE
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE COLLEAGUE, A
FRIEND AND A VALUED MEMBER OF
THIS CHAMBER. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE, DEDICATION AND
FRIENDSHIP, AND WE KNOW THAT
WE'LL CONTINUE YOUR PHILOSOPHY
THAT YOU SHARED WITH US IN YOUR
NEXT CHAPTER, WHICH IS A PLANT
TO PLANT, TREES WHOSE SHADE WILL
BENEFIT GENERATIONS TO COME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
OUR BODY AND BEING OUR
COLLEAGUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EVERYONE. I REALLY
HATE GOODBYES, I'LL JUST SAY
FOUR YEARS. I AM ENDING FOUR
YEARS HERE. AND AS THEY SAY, THE
DAYS ARE LONG AND THE YEARS ARE
SHORT. AND I DIDN'T LIKE THIS
PLACE VERY MUCH, SO I DECIDED TO
LEAVE AFTER ONE TERM. JUST
KIDDING, SO, JOSH BECKER,
MYSELF, DAVE CORTESE, ROSALIE
OCHOA, BOGH, AND THEN SUSAN
EGGMAN AS WELL CAME IN DURING A
VERY UNIQUE AND HISTORIC TIME.
WE WERE THE COVID CLASS AND FOR
ALL OF US EXCEPT SENATOR EGGMAN,
WE WERE FIRST TIME LEGISLATORS.
FIRST TIME IN THIS BODY WE CAME
IN. WE CAMPAIGNED AFTER THE
PRIMARY DURING A PERIOD OF COVID.
WE WERE SWORN IN. DURING COVID,
WE WERE UNDER HEAVY COVID
PROTOCOLS AND WE ALL REMEMBER
THE MASKING. THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND I WANT TO THANK
ERICA AND THE STAFF HERE FOR ALL
OF THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK TAKING
CARE OF US DURING THAT PERIOD
SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY, WHERE WE
WERE ABLE TO GET OUR WORK DONE,
WHETHER IT WAS THROUGH ZOOM
MEETINGS, THROUGH SOCIAL
DISTANCING HERE ON THE FLOOR.
AND I WILL JUST RECALL THAT MY
FIRST WEEK IN THE SENATE, I
ACTUALLY CAME DOWN WITH COVID
AND ERICA SENT ME A VERY NICE
CARE PACKAGE, AND I'M STILL
ACTUALLY NOT DONE WITH ALL THE
CHICKEN NOODLE SOUP FROM THAT
CARE PACKAGE STILL AT MY HOUSE.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO HAVE IT BACK.
ERICA. AND SO AFTER THAT FIRST
TWO YEARS WHEN WE KIND OF WERE
RESUMING, I MADE THE DECISION.
IT WAS A HARD ONE TO JUMP INTO A
DIFFERENT CAMPAIGN FOR A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF SEAT, MEANING
THAT I KNEW AT THAT POINT IN
TIME, MY TIME IN THE SENATE
WOULD BE COMING TO A CLOSE AT
THE END OF THIS YEAR. AND SO I
REALLY DIDN'T HAVE A NORMAL
SENATE EXPERIENCE. WE'VE HAD THE
CONSTRUCTION GOING ON THE LAST
TWO YEARS, AND SO EVERYONE
ALWAYS TELLS ME WHAT IT USED TO
BE LIKE, WHAT IT WILL BE LIKE IN
THE FUTURE. BUT I DIDN'T GET TO
HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE. BUT I'LL
JUST SAY, EVEN WITH THE
EXPERIENCE I'VE HAD, IT IS VERY
CLEAR TO ME WHAT A SPECIAL PLACE
WE GET TO WORK IN THE UNIQUE
CULTURE AND HISTORY AND REALLY
JUST NATURE, PERSONALITY OF THIS
BODY. AND I REALLY WANT TO THANK
PRO TEM EMERITUS TONY ATKINS.
PRO TEM MIKE MCGUIRE, FORMER PRO
TEM SCOTT WILK. AND I'M SORRY
FOR FORMER MINORITY LEADER SCOTT
WILK. I JUST GAVE YOU AN
ACCIDENTAL PROMOTION THERE.
CURRENT MINORITY LEADER BRIAN
JONES FOR ALL YOU'VE DONE TO
PROMOTE THIS CULTURE OF
COLLEGIALITY AND EMPATHY, THAT
THIS INSTITUTION REALLY
REPRESENTS, THIS BODY IS UNIQUE.
WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT IT, BUT
LOOKING AROUND, I CAN SAY
HONESTLY, WE DISAGREE AT TIMES.
BUT I LIKE YOU ALL. I'VE ENJOYED
WORKING WITH YOU AND I RESPECT
YOU. I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT I GET
TO SPEND MY DAYS WITH YOU, AND
THAT IS DEFINITELY NOT GOING TO
BE TRUE. IF I'M SUCCESSFUL IN MY
NEXT ENDEAVOR AND GET TO GO TO
WASHINGTON EVERY WEEK, THE
COLLEGIALITY, KINDNESS,
THOUGHTFUL ENGAGEMENT AND
DECENCY THAT THIS BODY TO ME
REPRESENTS ARE RARE AND
IMPORTANT VALUES IN TODAY'S
POLITICS. AT A TIME WHEN REALLY
POLITICS IS LACKING THESE
FUNDAMENTAL VALUES. AND I ALSO
WANT TO PARTICULARLY THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ORANGE COUNTY,
TOM UMBERG, JOSH NEUMANN FROM
FULLERTON, CATHERINE BREAKSPEAR
REPRESENTING ENCINITAS, JANET
NGUYEN FROM GARDEN GROVE, SANTA
ANA. IT'S REALLY BEEN SUCH A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU AND
TRYING TO ADVANCE THE UNIQUE
VALUES AND CONCERNS OF ORANGE
COUNTY, WHICH HAVE NOT ALWAYS
BEEN WELL REPRESENTED. NOW,
LOOK, WE LIVE AT A TIME WHEN
MANY OF THE CORE VALUES THAT I
CARE ABOUT DIVERSITY, INCLUSION,
FAIRNESS, BASIC ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY ARE SEEMINGLY AT
RISK IN THIS COUNTRY. AND SO
IT'S BEEN SO HEARTENING FOR ME
TO WATCH ALL OF YOU WORK TO
DEFEND AND STRENGTHEN THOSE
VALUES OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS.
AND I REALLY AM HONORED TO CALL
YOU COLLEAGUES. NOW, AS I THINK
SENATOR PORTENTINO MENTIONED
BEFORE, WE CAN'T DO ANY OF THIS
WITHOUT OUR STAFF. I JUST WANT
TO THANK MY STAFF, WHETHER IT'S
OUR CAPITOL STAFF UP HERE,
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE STAFF, DISTRICT STAFF
FOR ALL OF THEIR INCREDIBLE
WORK, AS WELL AS THE SUPPORTERS
WHO HAVE SUPPORTED MY BILLS
THROUGHOUT THE LAST FEW YEARS
AND GETTING THEM PASSED. WE KNOW
IT TAKES A VILLAGE TO GET ANY
LEGISLATION ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE, AND I'M THANKFUL TO ALL
THE FOLKS THAT THAT HELPED ME
GET MY BILLS DONE. NOW, I'LL
JUST REMIND YOU ALL THAT I HAVE
ANOTHER EIGHT YEARS POTENTIALLY
TO SERVE, SO I MAY DECIDE TO RUN
AGAIN AT SOME POINT AND COME
BACK SO WE COULD HAVE INSANITY
TO THE SEQUEL. BUT I DO HOPE
THAT WE'LL CONTINUE OUR
FRIENDSHIP, STAY IN TOUCH, AND
THAT WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING FOLLOWING YOUR
CAREERS. BECAUSE I'M SO EXCITED
ABOUT WHAT CALIFORNIA IS DOING.
SO EXCITED TO SEE WHAT YOU ALL
WILL CONTINUE TO DO AFTER THOSE
OF US WHO ARE LEAVING ARE GONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
EGGMAN.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO RECOGNIZE
THE SENATOR REPRESENTING
DISTRICT SEVEN. THAT IS SENATOR
GLAZER. SENATOR ALLEN, WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE REMARKS. WELL,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. IT'S
AN HONOR TO RISE TODAY, TO THANK
OUR GOOD COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND
FROM ORINDA, SENATOR STEVE
GLAZER, FOR HIS EXEMPLARY
SERVICE TO THIS BODY. WE ALL
KNOW THAT HE CAME UP THROUGH
POLITICS, SERVING FOR A LONG
LIST OF REALLY ESTEEMED
POLITICIANS WORKING FOR GRAY
DAVIS, AND THAT'S WHERE HE MET
HIS WONDERFUL WIFE, MELBA. THEY
WERE BOTH WORKING FOR GRAY,
DAVID ROBERTI, KATHLEEN BROWN,
MIKE WU, AND THEN, OF COURSE,
GOVERNOR, GOVERNOR BROWN. HE
WORKED ON GOVERNOR BROWN'S
CAMPAIGN. IN 2010, HE WAS
ACTUALLY HONORED BY THE NATIONAL
POLITICAL ASSOCIATION AS
STRATEGIST OF THE YEAR, AND THEN
ENDED UP SERVING WITH GOVERNOR
BROWN AS A SENIOR POLITICAL
ADVISOR, AND WAS EVENTUALLY
ELECTED TO JOIN OUR BODY THROUGH
A SPECIAL ELECTION IN 2015. NOW
YOU KNOW, SO MUCH OF OFTENTIMES
WE BRING OUR OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES TO THE BILLS THAT WE
BRING FORWARD. THEY'RE INSPIRED
BY OR AT LEAST INFORMED BY OUR
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES. AND THERE
ARE SO MANY EXAMPLES OF, OF
THOSE WITH SENATOR GLAZER. I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW.
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW HE'S
ACTUALLY SPOKEN ABOUT ON THE
FLOOR. HE WENT THROUGH A VERY
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE, HAVING
BEEN SHOT NOT TOO FAR FROM HIS
HOME, AND THAT EXPERIENCE
INFORMED MUCH OF HIS WORK. A LOT
OF THE EMPATHY THAT HE BROUGHT
TO HIS WORK, BUT INCLUDING SOME
IMPORTANT LEADERSHIP WORK IN THE
AREA OF GUN CONTROL, HE ALSO WAS
A PROUD GRADUATE OF THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM, ENDED
UP MAKING HIS WAY ALL THE WAY TO
THE TOP TO SERVE ON THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES. HE LOVES THAT
INSTITUTION, LOVES THE STUDENTS
IN THAT INSTITUTION, WAS DEVOTED
TO THAT INSTITUTION, BUT WAS
MORE DEVOTED TO THE STUDENTS
THAN TO THE INSTITUTION. AND I
THINK THAT THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT SHONE THROUGH HIS WORK,
BOTH ON THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
BUT BUT SPECIFICALLY THROUGH HIS
LEADERSHIP ON STUDENT SUCCESS,
TAKING ON THIS SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON STUDENT SUCCESS AND
THEN HOLDING HEARING AFTER
HEARING ABOUT A VERY SERIOUS
ISSUE WITHIN THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM, WHICH WAS THAT SO MANY
OF THE STUDENTS WERE GOING THERE
AND NOT GRADUATING ON TIME,
SPENDING YEARS AND YEARS, IN
SOME CASES LANGUISHING, SPENDING
A LOT OF MONEY AND A LOT OF TIME
IN THE SYSTEM WITHOUT SUCCESS.
AND HE WAS DOGGED ABOUT THIS
ISSUE, HOLDING THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE,
HOLDING HEARING AFTER HEARING,
AND EVENTUALLY CREATING A SYSTEM
THAT'S NOW RESEARCHING AND
TRACKING THE PROGRESS OF
STUDENTS THROUGH FROM K THROUGH
12 THROUGH COLLEGE AS THEY ENTER
THE WORKFORCE, AND REALLY HAS
DONE SOME IMPORTANT WORK IN
ENSURING ON TIME GRADUATION. AND
IF YOU THINK OF WHAT THAT REALLY
MEANS FOR A YOUNG PERSON AND
THEIR ABILITY TO START ON THEIR
CAREER AND START THEIR LIVES
AFTER SCHOOL WITH WITH LESS
DEBT, IT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE OF A,
OF A VERY SERIOUS CONTRIBUTION
THAT HE MADE. AND IT'S ALSO A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF STEVE'S
CONTINUAL FOCUS ON TRYING TO
FOCUS ON, ON, ON, ON POLICY
RATHER THAN THE POLITICS. THIS
WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WAS A SEXY
ISSUE THAT HAD A LOT OF SPECIAL
INTEREST GROUPS INVOLVED AND
LOBBYISTS. BUT HE RECOGNIZED
THAT THIS WAS A PROBLEM THAT WAS
IMPACTING YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE THAT REALLY NEEDED SOME
ATTENTION AND TIME AND HE DUG IN
AND SPENT TIME ON IT, AND IT WAS
REFLECTIVE OF WHO HE IS AND SOME
OF THOSE GOVERNING PRINCIPLES,
OF COURSE, THAT HE HAS ON THIS
WONDERFUL BASEBALL CARD THAT MY
SON JUST TOLD ME THIS WEEKEND
THAT I NEED TO GET FOR MYSELF,
THAT IT'S ALL ABOUT TRYING TO
PUT POLICY OVER POLITICS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THIS IS HIS
DEVOTION TO JOURNALISM, HIS
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
JOURNALISM TO THE HEALTH AND
STRENGTH OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY,
THE FACT THAT OUR NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN HEMORRHAGING
AND SUFFERING. AND HE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT AN ENORMOUS
IMPACT THAT HAS AND THAT CAN
HAVE ON THE STRENGTH AND HEALTH
OF OUR DEMOCRACY. AND HE'S
FOCUSED LIKE A, LIKE A, LIKE A
LASER ON THAT ISSUE AS WELL. WE
ALL KNOW, OF COURSE, THE WORK
HE'S DOING RIGHT NOW, RATHER
RADICAL, GROUNDBREAKING WORK ON
TRYING TO HELP RETHINKING
FINANCING OF THE JOURNALISM
INDUSTRY AND NEWSPAPERS. BUT BUT
ONE LITTLE EXAMPLE TO TELL YOU
ALL ABOUT WHILE WHEN WE WERE
ASKED TO DO DISTRICT ASKS FOR
OUR BUDGETS, HE DECIDED TO PUT
HIS DISTRICT DOLLARS, DIRECT HIS
DISTRICT DOLLARS TO CREATE A
STATEWIDE JOURNALISM FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM TO BOLSTER DEMOCRACY IN
THE MEDIA, WHERE THEY'RE FUNDING
YOUNG PEOPLE OUT OF A CENTER IN
BERKELEY THAT ARE GOING ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, WORKING
FOR ETHNIC MEDIA, FOR LOCAL
PRESS, FOR LARGER NEWSPAPERS,
DOING THE HARD WORK OF, OF, OF,
OF INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM IN
TOWN AFTER TOWN AND CITY HALLS,
HALLS OF ADMINISTRATION IN THE
COUNTIES, THESE THESE CHAMBERS
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE ENSURING
THAT THE PUBLIC CAN HAVE A LIGHT
SHONE ON THE IMPORTANT WORK OF
GOVERNMENT. AND IT'S ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF HIM OF HIM LATCHING
ON TO A PROBLEM, TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND PUTTING
THOSE PROBLEM SOLVER SKILLS THAT
MARKED HIS ENTIRE CAREER TO
ADDRESS A REAL PUBLIC POLICY
CHALLENGE HERE IN OUR STATE.
NOW, OF COURSE, SENATOR GLAZIER,
IS SOMEONE WHO, UNLIKE MANY OF
US, SEEMS TO CARE. I THINK MORE
ABOUT HIS VOTES THAN THE BILLS
THAT HE RUNS IN FACT, HE'S
FAMOUSLY SAID A FEW TIMES, LOVE
COMES AND GOES, BUT YOUR VOTE IS
FOREVER. AND YOU KNOW, I THINK
THAT'S REFLECTIVE OF THE OF WHO
HE IS. HE WANTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ALL DOING OUR
IMPORTANT WORK OF OVERSIGHT, NOT
ONLY OF THE ADMINISTRATION, BUT
OF EACH OTHER, AND THAT
SOMETIMES WE CAN BE A LITTLE BIT
TOO MUCH OF A BILL FACTORY. AND
A LOT OF HIS FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT HE FEELS
COMFORTABLE WITH THE POLICIES
THAT HE'S LOOKING TO, EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. YOU KNOW
THAT. AND HE SPENDS TIME DIGGING
INTO RESEARCH AND THE FACTS,
CONSIDERING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES, FISCAL IMPACTS,
AND ALL OF THOSE SORTS OF ISSUES
THAT MAY, MAY BE, MAY, MAY, MAY,
MAY BE A PART OF A BILL THAT
DON'T END UP GETTING DISCUSSED
VERY MUCH. AND I THINK IT SPEAKS
TO, TO, TO, TO, TO, TO THOSE,
THOSE GOVERNING PRINCIPLES THAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED. HE'S I, I JUST
FOUND OUT, I THINK YESTERDAY
THAT I WAS GOING TO DO THIS
SPEECH. SO I WOKE UP A COUPLE
TIMES OVER IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT TO WRITE DOWN SOME, SOME
KIND OF WORDS THAT DESCRIBE
STEVE GLAZER. AND I. SO I HAD
THIS LITTLE LIST THAT I JUST
KIND OF SAT BY MY BED AND I
RECOPIED THEM HERE. SO I WANT TO
JUST GO OVER A COUPLE OF THEM
BECAUSE I THINK THEY THEY
REFLECT WHO WHO HE IS AND
OCCASIONAL ICONOCLAST,
THOUGHTFUL, PRINCIPLED. I WANT
TO SAY THAT HE HAS A SOFT TOUCH.
YOU KNOW, HE'S HE'S SOMEONE VERY
STRONG FEELINGS AND OPINIONS
SOMETIMES. BUT HE'S REALLY
MOTIVATED BY LEARNING WHAT
DRIVES YOU AND WHY AND WHAT WHAT
THE REASONS ARE BEHIND
SOMETHING. HE'S NOT TRYING TO.
HE'S NOT THE KIND OF MEMBER THAT
GETS IN YOUR FACE AND IS TRYING
TO FORCE AN OUTCOME UPON YOU. SO
HE'S GOT A SOFT TOUCH. HE'S VERY
KIND, ONE THING I HEARD LAST
WEEK AT HIS FAREWELL PARTY WHEN
MANY OF HIS STAFF CAME AND SPOKE
ABOUT HIS KINDNESS, THERE WAS A,
YOU KNOW, A PROFESSIONALISM AND
IN A, IN A SORT OF DEMANDING
BOSS IN MANY RESPECTS, HE
EXPECTS A CERTAIN HIGH LEVEL OF
PERFORMANCE FROM HIS TEAM. BUT
THERE'S A CONSISTENCY THERE AND
A AND A CONSISTENT KINDNESS THAT
THAT ALWAYS SHONE THROUGH. HE'S
ACTUALLY SURPRISINGLY FUNNY.
I'VE GOTTEN TO SEE THAT IN A
COUPLE OCCASIONS, OF COURSE HE'S
AN OENOPHILE. HIS LOVE AND
KNOWLEDGE OF WINE, YOU KNOW,
MATCHES AND PERHAPS EVEN
SURPASSES THAT OF THE GREAT KING
OF NAPA, SENATOR BILL DODD. AND
WE'VE ALL OF COURSE, BEEN, YOU
KNOW, BENEFICIARIES OF THAT LOVE
AND KNOWLEDGE OF WINE. HE'S VERY
RESPECTFUL. HE'S RESPECTFUL OF
EVERYBODY, NO MATTER THEIR
POLITICS AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT HE SHOWS CONSISTENTLY. HE'S
SHARP, HE'S GENEROUS. HE'S
INDEPENDENT. AND THE FINAL THING
I WANT I WROTE DOWN WAS HIS
DEVOTION TO FAMILY, HIS LOVE FOR
FAMILY. I THINK THAT'S REFLECTED
BY THE PRESENCE OF HIS DAUGHTER
HERE TODAY REPRESENTS HER SISTER
AS WELL, OF COURSE, HIS
WONDERFUL WIFE, MELBA. WE'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRAVEL WITH
HIM. I SEE, SENATOR BRAZEAU. WE
TRAVELED TOGETHER NOT TOO LONG
AGO. I KNOW HOW DEVOTED THEY
ARE. HIS FAMILY IS TO HIM, AND
JUST AS MUCH AS HE IS TO THEM, I
OF COURSE, I SEE WHAT A GREAT
DAD HE IS NOW. I ALSO GOT A
LITTLE WINDOW INTO WHAT A GREAT
DAD HE MUST HAVE BEEN WHEN HIS
KIDS WERE LITTLE, BECAUSE HE'S
HAD THE CHANCE TO HANG OUT WITH
MY LITTLE SON AND TO SEE STEVE
LIGHT UP AND PLAY WITH LITTLE
EZRA. THEY PLAY SPIDER-MAN
TOGETHER. HE DOES MAGIC TRICKS.
HE TELLS GOOFY JOKES. I MEAN,
I'VE JUST GOTTEN A CHANCE TO SEE
A TOTALLY DIFFERENT SIDE OF
SENATOR GLAZIER. THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY FUN AND SILLY AND BUT BUT
SO GOOD HEARTED AND FILLED WITH
WITH KINDNESS AND JOY AND SO I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU, STEVE,
FOR, FOR, FOR BEING A GREAT
FRIEND. AND, AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THIS
STATE AND TO THIS INSTITUTION.
YOU HAVE REALLY UPLIFTED, STRONG
VALUES HERE. YOU'VE YOU'VE,
YOU'VE, YOU'VE YOU'VE DEVOTED
YOURSELF WITH GREAT INTEGRITY
HERE. AND WE'RE GOING TO MISS
YOU A LOT. I KNOW THAT THAT
MELBA IS GOING TO LIKE HAVING
YOU HOME MORE. AND I KNOW YOU
GUYS ARE GOING TO GO ON TO DO
SOME GREAT THINGS IN YOUR NEXT
CHAPTER, BUT YOU'VE DONE SO MUCH
FOR THIS STATE. YOU'VE DONE A
GREAT, GREAT WORK FOR THIS
INSTITUTION. AND I JUST WANT TO
APPRECIATE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FRIENDSHIP AND SERVICE.
SENATOR WILK IS NEXT. MADAM
PRESIDENT, I YIELD THE FLOOR TO
SENATOR ALLEN. HE DID TAKE TEN
MINUTES SO THAT WORKS, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I STAND IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY SURPRISED AND
BEWILDERED BECAUSE STEVE GLAZER
IS ONE OF MY POLITICAL HEROES.
AND I'M ALWAYS PRAISING HIM. AND
HE DOESN'T TAKE IT VERY WELL, SO
I JUST DON'T. AND YOU'RE ALREADY
RED, SO I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
BECAUSE, HE'S HE'S THAT HUMBLE,
WHICH HE SHOULDN'T BE HUMBLE
BECAUSE HE, HE CAN BACK UP
ANYTHING HE SAYS OR HE DOESN'T
BELIEVE ME. SO I'M HOPING HE'S
HUMBLE. AND BECAUSE I GO ROGUE
SOMETIMES NOT NOT SENATOR ALLEN
ROGUE, BUT I GO ROGUE. I HAD TO
SEND MY SCRIPT TO HIM TO SIGN
OFF, BUT I'VE ADDED A FEW THINGS
BECAUSE I HAD TO GO ROGUE. SO
BEFORE I EVEN MET STEVE, I WAS
ALREADY IMPRESSED WITH HIM
BECAUSE I HAD SEEN HIS LITTLE
BASEBALL PLAYING CARD. AND YOU
KNOW, YOU CAN DO THIS. YOU CAN
DO THIS JOB AND NOT DO ANYTHING,
AND NO ONE AT HOME IS GOING TO
KNOW. AND HE WAS WILLING TO MAKE
HIMSELF ACCOUNTABLE BY LAYING
OUT HIS TEN GOVERNING PRINCIPLES
AND PRINCIPLE. NUMBER THREE IS
PURSUE BIPARTISAN DECISIONS THAT
ARE ALWAYS BETTER AND LONGER
LASTING RESULTS. SO THAT'S
THAT'S I'M GOING TO HOLD IT TO
THAT. HOW ABOUT THAT? SO HE'S
ALWAYS BEEN WILLING TO WORK
ACROSS THE AISLE AND HE'S ALWAYS
PROVIDED FRIENDSHIP AND LOYALTY
TO ALL THOSE THAT HAVE WORKED
WITH HIM BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
CROSS THAT, THAT PARTIZAN
DIVIDE. AND TO ME, HE'S ALWAYS
KEPT HIS WORD. AND I THINK YOU
PROBABLY HAVE SHARED THE SAME
EXPERIENCE NOW. FOUR YEARS AGO,
HE WAS CHAIR OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE, AND WE
HAD A VERY CONTROVERSIAL BILL
FROM, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD. YOU
MAY REMEMBER THE NURSE
PRACTITIONER BILL. AND AS YOU
KNOW, I SEE A COUPLE OF FORMER
BNP CHAIRS, AS YOU KNOW, SCOPE
OF PRACTICE BILLS ARE QUITE
INTENSE, VERY CONTENTIOUS. AND
THIS ONE PARTICULARLY SO IT HAD
FAILED IN THE PAST, CLEARED THE
ASSEMBLY BACK INTO THE SENATE.
AND SENATOR GLAZER AT THE TIME
WAS CHAIR, AND HE DID SOMETHING
REALLY UNUSUAL THAT MOST PEOPLE
DON'T DO PARTICULARLY CHAIRS. HE
BROUGHT TOGETHER TWO REPUBLICANS
AND TWO DEMOCRATS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THAT HAD NOT MADE A
DECISION TO DISCUSS THE BILL
AND, AND, AND SEEK A COMPROMISE.
THAT'S GOOD PUBLIC POLICY. NOW,
I'M THINKING ABOUT IT BASED UPON
THE COMMITTEE. IT SHOULD HAVE
ONLY BEEN ONE REPUBLICAN, NOT
TWO. SO YOU'RE VERY GRACIOUS.
AND SO WE WERE. YOU KNOW, WE
WORKED THROUGH THAT FOR A NUMBER
OF WEEKS. WE FINALLY CAME UP
WITH A BILL THAT WE THOUGHT
COULD PASS AND WAS GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY, AND WE PASSED IT OUT OF
THE COMMITTEE. NOW, FOR ME, THAT
WAS PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING,
CHALLENGING BECAUSE IT WAS AN
ELECTION YEAR AND I WAS UP FOR
REELECTION. AND OF COURSE, ONE
OF THE OPPONENTS OF THE BILL,
VERY POWERFUL SPECIAL INTEREST
UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AND
GLAZER KNEW THAT IF I WAS GOING
TO GO UP ON THE BILL, THAT IT
WOULD CREATE SOME POLITICAL
JEOPARDY FOR ME. BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, WE CAME TOGETHER IN
WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS A REASONABLE
BILL, AND I WAS ONE OF THE KEY
VOTES TO PASS IT OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND OF COURSE, IT
WENT ON TO PASS THE SENATE BACK
TO THE ASSEMBLY. AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED IT. FAST FORWARD
A FEW MONTHS LATER, DURING MY
REELECTION, AND SENATOR GLAZER,
PRIOR TO THE FALL, HAD COMMITTED,
HE SAID, YOU'RE A GREAT SENATOR.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET INVOLVED IN
YOUR RACE. AND TO HIS CREDIT, HE
DID NOT. I HAD OTHER PEOPLE SAY
THAT. BY THE WAY, BUT HE HE
STUCK TO HIS HE STUCK TO HIS
WORD AND HE KEPT IT. AND THAT
FINAL WEEKEND HE CALLED ME TO
SEE HOW I WAS DOING BECAUSE IT
WAS IT WAS IT WAS A TOUGH RACE.
AND HE WISHED HE WISHED ME WELL.
AND I REALLY I REALLY
APPRECIATED THAT CALL. AND
THERE'S CONSEQUENCES WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU TAKE DECISIONS UP HERE
AND HE WE CAME BACK AFTER THE
ELECTION AND HE LOST HIS
CHAIRMANSHIP AS A CHAIR OF
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS, AND HE
KNEW HE WAS GOING TO PAY THAT
PRICE IF HE DID WHAT HE DID. BUT
IT'S ABOUT DOING THE RIGHT THING.
IT'S ABOUT HONESTY AND INTEGRITY
AND FRIENDSHIP. AND Ã REALLY
HAVE ALWAYS, ALWAYS REALLY
VALUED HIS LEADERSHIP IN THAT
RESPECT. I THINK ALL OF US
COULD, COULD DRAW FROM STEVE'S,
EXAMPLE UP HERE. HE'S GOING TO
BE HE'S GOING TO BE SORELY
MISSED. AND HE'S ALWAYS FOCUSED
ON, YOU KNOW, CONSTRUCTIVE
SOLUTIONS LIKE, LIKE SENATOR
ALLEN SAID, HE DOES HAVE STRONG
OPINIONS, BUT HE HAS SUCH A SOFT
TOUCH AND I THINK HE'S GOING TO
BE GREATLY MISSED. AND FOR ME,
IF YOU LOOK AT HIS CARD WITH
PRINCIPLE NUMBER TEN IS CONDUCT
MYSELF ALWAYS WITH HONESTY AND
INTEGRITY, HONESTY AND INTEGRITY.
AND I CAN SAY THAT IN YOUR
ENTIRE TIME UP HERE, YOU'VE
CONDUCTED YOURSELF WITH HONESTY
AND INTEGRITY, AND YOU REMAIN
ONE OF MY POLITICAL HEROES AND
REALLY APPRECIATE OUR FRIENDSHIP.
AND YOU WON'T SHARE WITH ME WHAT
YOU'RE DOING NEXT, BUT I HOPE
IT'S SOMETHING IN THE PUBLIC
POLICY REALM, BECAUSE YOU'RE AN
IMPORTANT VOICE FOR OUR STATE.
AND WITH THAT, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SERVICE. ESTÁ NÓI NHÀ.
THE MEMBERS STILL NEEDS TO SPEAK.
AS A PRESIDING OFFICER, I KNOW
THAT WAS IN VIOLATION. AND MY
APOLOGIES, MADAM PRESIDENT.
WELL, THOSE ARE GRACIOUS WORDS,
SENATOR ALLEN. SENATOR WILK,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
KINDNESSES. BIPARTISANSHIP HAS
BEEN A PART OF MY SERVICE UP
HERE. AND I'M FOCUSED ON POLICY
HAS BEEN, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE I
THINK HAVE BEEN SOMEWHAT
SURPRISED BY ME BECAUSE I WAS
SUCH A POLITICAL ANIMAL BEFORE I
GOT ELECTED, BUT I'LL TELL YOU,
AND I TELL MY STAFF, DON'T TALK
TO ME ABOUT POLITICS. I'M DONE
WITH THAT. IT'S ALL ABOUT
POLICY. SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I WANTED TO FOCUS ON. AND I
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION OF
THAT, AS OTHER SENATORS HAVE
DONE FROM THE START, NOTHING
THAT I COULD HAVE DONE OR
ACCOMPLISHED IN MY TIME WOULD
HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT THE
STRENGTH AND HARD WORK OF MY
STAFF, AND I KNOW THAT THEY ARE
HERE OR LISTENING. AND THAT'S
NOT JUST MY CAPITAL STAFF, BUT
MY DISTRICT STAFF AND MY
COMMITTEE STAFF. I HAVE BEEN A
CHALLENGING SENATOR TO I, MY
APOLOGIES TO OUR LEADERSHIP
BECAUSE I'M NOT ALWAYS THE
EASIEST ONE, MEANS I'VE HAD A
LOT OF CHAIRMANSHIPS AND A LOT
OF DIFFERENT COMMITTEE STAFF. SO
I THINK HALF THE BUILDING
COMMITTEE STAFF HERE HAVE BEEN
WITH ME AT SOME POINT OR
ANOTHER, AND I SO APPRECIATE
THEM. YOU CAN'T AGAIN SPEAK ON
THIS FLOOR WITHOUT EXPRESSING
YOUR APPRECIATION FOR KATRINA
AND THE SERGEANT STAFF THAT WE
HAVE. THANK YOU ALL. YOU CAN'T
BE ON THIS FLOOR AND NOT EXPRESS
APPRECIATION TO BERNIE AND THE
DESK STAFF. SO INCREDIBLE. YOU
CAN'T BE ON THIS FLOOR.
CERTAINLY AT THIS MOMENT IN
TIME, AND NOT EXPRESS DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR ERICA AND THE
RULES COMMITTEE STAFF. H.R. AND
US HAVE NOT ALWAYS BEEN EXACTLY
TOGETHER, BUT IT'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY TEAM THAT YOU HAVE
BUILT TO MAKE US ALL SAFE AND TO
DO OUR BEST WORK. AND WE AND I
AM SO VERY, VERY GRATEFUL TO
THAT. OF COURSE, I'M JOINED BY
MY DAUGHTER, ALEX. WE CAN'T DO
OUR WORK WITHOUT OUR FAMILY
BEING SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT WE DO.
MY WIFE, MELBA, MY OTHER
DAUGHTER, ARIEL. I SOMETIMES
THINK THAT THE BEST PART ABOUT
THIS JOB IS I'M NOT OUTVOTED ALL
THE TIME. LIKE I AM AT HOME. SO
SOMETIMES GOING TO WORK CAN BE A
POSITIVE, BUT I HAVE BEEN
BLESSED BY GREAT LEADERSHIP OF
THE HOUSE HERE IN THE SENATE.
SENATOR ATKINS, THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR SUPPORT AND HELP DURING
THE YEARS. SENATOR MCGUIRE.
LIKEWISE, SENATOR DELEON WAS MY
EARLY YEARS HERE AS WELL. AND I
KNOW I'M NOT THE EASIEST MEMBER
TO WORK WITH. YOU KNOW, I VOTE
95 EVERY EVERY YEAR AFTER
SESSION, I ASK MY STAFF, HOW DO
I HOW DID I DO? AND ONE OF THE
GAUGES IS TO GO AND TAKE THE
VOTES OF THE LEADER AND COMPARE
MY VOTES IN THAT REGARD. AND I
THIS IS MY 10TH YEAR AND IT'S
BEEN 95%. AND THAT IN SOME WAYS
FOR PEOPLE OUT IN THE OUTSIDE
MIGHT SAY, WOW, THAT'S REALLY
GOOD. BUT I ALSO KNOW IT MEANS
THAT THERE'S A FEW VOTES THAT I,
I DIDN'T ALWAYS GO ALONG WITH.
AND THAT'S, THAT'S SOMEWHAT CAN
BE SOMEWHAT CHALLENGING. YOU
KNOW, I FIRST ARRIVED HERE IN
THE IN THE STATE CAPITOL IN
1979, 1979. I KNOW I LOOK PRETTY
YOUNG, BUT I'VE HAD A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO OBSERVE AND BE IN
AND AROUND THIS BUILDING. I
WORKED FOR THE PRO TEM FOR A
LITTLE OVER SIX YEARS. MY OFFICE
WAS RIGHT OFF THE FLOOR THERE
AND GOT A FIRST HAND LOOK AT HOW
THE SENATE OPERATED IN THE 1980S
AND THE EARLY 1990S. AND I
LEARNED A LOT. AND THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF CHANGES, SOME GOOD,
SOME BAD, SOME DIFFERENT. I HAVE
TO SAY THAT, OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS, I THINK THAT THE, THE
CULTURE OF THIS PLACE OF THE
SENATE HAS REALLY ELEVATED, IN
MY OPINION, IT'S ELEVATED IN HOW
WE GET ALONG. AND I KNOW THAT
COMES FROM THE GREAT LEADERSHIP
OF OUR OF OUR TEAM HERE IN THE
SENATE TO HELP FOSTER THAT. WE
CAN HAVE DIFFERENCES, BUT WE CAN
GET ALONG. YOU KNOW, WHEN I
FIRST RAN FOR THIS OFFICE, I
DIDN'T RUN ON A SINGLE ISSUE. I
DIDN'T SAY, I'M GOING TO BE THE
EDUCATION SENATOR OR YOUR
TRANSPORTATION SENATOR OR
WHATEVER THE SUBJECT MATTER WAS.
I SAID THAT I WOULD I WOULD COME
UP HERE IF I WAS ELECTED AND
SUPPORT A CULTURE OF PROBLEM
SOLVING, A PROBLEM SOLVING OVER
PARTIZANSHIP AND MAYBE THAT'S
WHY IN MY ELECTION, I ACTUALLY
GOT WELL, I GOT VOTES FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE, I THINK,
WHICH IS WHY I ENDED UP BEING
HERE. I WANT TO SHARE AS I
FINISH, MY FAVORITE QUOTE FROM
JERRY BROWN, GOVERNOR BROWN, HE
SAID THIS ON OCCASION. HE SAID,
I KNOW MORE THAN MOST, BUT ONLY
HALF OF WHAT I NEED TO KNOW. AND
IT WAS A GREAT, IT WAS A GREAT
MENTORSHIP FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME. I
KNOW THAT I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU WONDERFUL COLLEAGUES ON, ON
BILLS AND THE ISSUES OF THE DAY.
AND I KNOW I ASK A LOT OF
QUESTIONS, AND I KNOW SOMETIMES
THAT CAN BE A LITTLE BOTHERSOME,
BUT IT REALLY COMES FROM THAT,
THAT, THAT MARK THAT JERRY BROWN
MADE ON ME, WHICH IS THAT DON'T
THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
EVERYTHING. YOU JUST YOU SIMPLY
DO NOT. AND YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE
AN OPEN MIND NOW, SOMETIMES,
CERTAINLY, AS IT RELATES TO
ADMINISTRATION, YOU CAN GET INTO
A PARALYSIS SPACE, BUT YOU KNOW,
WE GOT TO VOTE. YOU KNOW,
THERE'S NO PUTTING SOMETHING OFF
ON THIS FLOOR. AND THERE'S
OCCASIONS WHERE YOU CAN LAY OFF,
BUT YOU'RE EXPECTED TO MAKE A
DECISION. BUT IT MEANS FOR ME AT
LEAST, IT MEANS I'VE NEVER TRIED
TO RUSH TO A DECISION. AND IT
MEANS THAT I'VE ENGAGED WITH
YOU, HOPEFULLY CONSTRUCTIVELY
AND HONESTLY, ABOUT QUESTIONS TO
HELP ME GET TO A PLACE OF. AND I
ALWAYS THINK TRYING TO GET TO A
PLACE OF YES. AND FINALLY, LET
ME JUST SAY THAT THE FOUNDATION
OF OUR WORK HERE IS TRUST. TRUST
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT,
AND I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT THE
BEST EXPLANATION FROM A MEMBER
ON ANY ISSUE WAS, THIS IS HOW I
THINK MY DISTRICT FEELS ABOUT
THAT MATTER. AND THAT'S A GREAT
TOUCHSTONE FOR OUR WORK. HOW
YOUR DISTRICT FEELS. BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY, IT'S ABOUT TRUST
THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE IN THE WORK
THAT WE DO AND TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT. AND AS SENATOR ALLEN
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, IT'S SOMETHING THAT I
NEVER THOUGHT WOULD BE AS
FRAGILE AS I FEEL ABOUT IT
TODAY. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU FEEL
THE SAME WAY, BUT I CERTAINLY
DO. AND IT'S BEEN DRIVING A LOT
OF HOW I HOPE TO HAVE CONDUCTED
MYSELF, AND A LOT OF HOW I HOPE
WE WILL UNDERSTAND THAT THAT BIG
CONCEPT OF DEMOCRACY IS NOT
SOMETHING OUT THERE. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IT'S IN OUR HANDS
HERE THAT WE CAN CONTROL AND
THAT WE CAN INFLUENCE. AND IT'S
FRAGILE AND WE CAN'T TAKE IT FOR
GRANTED. I'VE BEEN BLESSED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS WORK FOR IN MY
10TH YEAR NOW. I THANK YOU ALL
FOR ALL THE KINDNESSES THAT
YOU'VE EXTENDED TO ME IN OUR
WORK TOGETHER. THIS IMPORTANT
WORK OF DEMOCRACY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GLAZER. WE HAVE TWO MORE
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE RECOGNIZING
SENATOR SKINNER, WHO REPRESENTS
DISTRICT NINE. SENATOR WAHAB
WILL BEGIN HER REMARKS. SO,
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO RECOGNIZE
MY SEATMATE DISTRICT NEIGHBOR
AND FRIEND, SENATOR NANCY
SKINNER. I THINK THAT MANY OF US
WHO HAVE SERVED WITH SENATOR
SKINNER EASILY KNOW THAT SHE'S
ONE OF THE MOST WELL-READ
INDIVIDUALS ON ANY SUBJECT
MATTER. AND I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT I ALWAYS
JOKE WITH SENATOR SKINNER, AND I
LITERALLY JUST CALL HER SKINNER,
THAT THE FACT THAT SHE WAS CHAIR
OF PUBLIC SAFETY FOR THE AMOUNT
OF YEARS THAT SHE WAS, IT'S A
HARD JOB. AND I THINK PEOPLE
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND YOU KNOW, I'LL GO THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT SHE HAS
WORKED ON. AND THE ONE THING
THAT I DO WANT TO SAY ABOUT
SENATOR SKINNER IS THE FACT THAT
SHE HAS GENUINELY CHAMPIONED A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT WE ALL THINK
ARE IMPORTANT AND IN A WAY
THAT'S VERY THOUGHTFUL AND VERY
CONSIDERATE OF ALL SIDES OF AN
ARGUMENT. AND SHE OFTEN HAS A
VERY HONEST OUTLOOK ON WHAT'S
EXACTLY HAPPENING AND WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN. YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT STATUS QUO AND
HOLDING FIRM TO THOSE VALUES,
BUT IT'S ALSO SAYING, OKAY,
WHERE DO WE NEED TO GO AND
WHETHER OR NOT THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE IS MOVING US FORWARD. AND
ON ISSUES LIKE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
INSTITUTION AND INDUSTRY, A
SITUATION THAT LARGELY IS NOT
TOUCHED BY MANY ELECTED
OFFICIALS BECAUSE IT'S A SCARY
THING TO TOUCH, WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT ON A LOCAL
LEVEL OR EVEN A STATEWIDE LEVEL.
SENATOR SKINNER HAS PUSHED THE
ISSUES THAT MATTER TO PEOPLE
FORWARD, AND THE ONE CONSTANT
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE UPON IS
THAT CHANGE IS CONSTANT. AND SO
NOTHING CAN JUST STAY THE SAME.
AND SENATOR SKINNER KNOWS THAT
BETTER THAN ANYBODY. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT SENATOR
SKINNER, SHE IS FROM BERKELEY,
AND SHE WAS THE FIRST STUDENT
THAT WENT TO UC BERKELEY THAT
GOT ELECTED TO CITY COUNCIL.
OKAY, SO IMAGINE THIS MANY YEARS
AGO, AND SENATOR SKINNER KNOWS
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE THE NEW KID
ON THE BLOCK. AND SHE'S ALWAYS
REMEMBERED THAT MAKING SURE THAT
AS SHE PROMOTES MORE WOMEN BEING
IN LEADERSHIP, AS SHE PROMOTES
MORE WOMEN BEING RECOGNIZED, IN
FACT, SHE NEVER VOTES ON ANY
TYPE OF SITUATION WHERE THEY
NAME A BRIDGE, A STREET, A
FREEWAY THAT'S NAMED AFTER A MAN.
SHE SAYS. IT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE.
OKAY SO SHE FOCUSES ON THE
ISSUES THAT THAT SHE CARES
ABOUT. AND AS THE CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS, SHE PRIORITIZED
WOMEN WINNING AND MORE THAN
THAT, SHE PRIORITIZED
PROGRESSIVE WOMEN WINNING. AND
IN FACT, SHE HAS LED THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS TO BE EQUITABLE, TO BE
THOUGHTFUL, TO BE MORE COHESIVE.
AND THE REALITY IS THAT WHEN I
WON MY SEAT AND I WAS RUNNING
THE ENTIRE TIME, SENATOR SKINNER
WOULD CALL TO CHECK IN. HEY,
HAVE YOU DONE THIS? ALL YOU NEED
TO DO IS THIS YOU NEED TO TALK
TO THIS. AND WHEN I FINALLY WON,
SHE HAD A CONVERSATION. I WON'T
FORGET IT. AND SHE TOLD ME,
OKAY, SO HERE'S THE LOWDOWN ON
THE SENATE. THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO. THIS IS THE
STRUCTURE. THINK OF THIS PERSON
AS THE CITY MANAGER, THIS PERSON
AS THE CITY CLERK, THIS PERSON
AS THAT. JUST TO LET ME KNOW HOW
THIS INSTITUTION OPERATES. AND
SHE TOLD ME YOU COULD PISS OFF
ANYBODY YOU WANT IF YOU CARE
ABOUT THE ISSUE. BUT THERE'S
ROUGHLY THREE PEOPLE YOU DON'T
PISS OFF. AND I SAID, OKAY, LET
ME WRITE DOWN THEIR NAMES. AND
SHE SAID, YOU DON'T PISS OFF
KIMBERLY RODRIGUEZ, OKAY? AND
YOU DON'T PISS OFF BERNIE, AND
YOU DON'T PISS OFF SECRETARY
CONTRERAS. AND I WAS LIKE, OKAY,
WHY? AND SHE GOES, I'LL TELL YOU
LATER. BUT RIGHT NOW I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN YOU COME
IN, YOU DON'T PISS OFF THESE
PEOPLE. BUT EVERYBODY ELSE IS
FREE GAME, OKAY? AND I SAID,
OKAY, GREAT. AND CLEARLY LAST
YEAR UPSET A COUPLE PEOPLE I
THINK. AND BUT I DIDN'T UPSET
THE PEOPLE THAT SHE MENTIONED. I
WAS VERY COGNIZANT OF THAT.
RIGHT. BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO
FOLLOW SENATOR SKINNER'S ADVICE
AND ANYTIME YOU HAD A TOUGH DAY,
SHE WOULD HER PEP TALK IS LIKE,
YEAH, 100%. YOU ARE UPSETTING
THE RIGHT PEOPLE. YOU'RE DOING
EXACTLY WHAT YOU NEED TO DO. YOU
KEEP MOVING FORWARD. AND I WAS
ALWAYS HAPPY TO HEAR FROM HER,
THAT SHE AGREED ON A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO DO OR I
THOUGHT WAS RIGHT. AND
OFTENTIMES YOU GUYS ALL KNOW I
CAN'T SIT STILL. BUT WHEN I
WOULD SIT IN MY CHAIR, SENATOR
SKINNER, WHO, MY ENTIRE TIME
WITH HER HERE, SHE WORE A MASK.
AND I'M A LITTLE HARD OF
HEARING, AND I'D MAKE HER REPEAT
THE SAME THING, LIKE, FIVE TIMES
UNTIL SHE LIFTED HER MASK AND
SAID, I SAID THIS, AND WE WOULD
DEBATE ABOUT WHY DID YOU VOTE
THIS WAY? WHY DID YOU VOTE THAT
WAY? AND IT WAS ALWAYS A GOOD,
ROBUST DISCUSSION, ALWAYS FILLED
WITH JOKES AND, YOU KNOW, JUST
JUST HONEST HUMANITY. AND SHE
WOULD KNOW THAT SOMETIMES WHEN
YOU WOULD DO SOMETHING THAT WAS
TOUGH, THAT IT'S ALSO HARD,
RIGHT, THAT SOMETIMES IT LEADS
YOU TO BEING UPSET. SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE THINGS GOING ON IN YOUR
PERSONAL LIFE. SOMETIMES YOU
HAVE THINGS GOING ON THAT YOU
KNOW YOU'RE HAVING A BAD DAY.
AND I THINK SENATOR SKINNER
KNOWS THAT. AND SHE BRINGS, AN
HONEST EAR, A SUPPORTIVE WORD,
AND A LOT OF JUST ENCOURAGEMENT.
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT SENATOR
SKINNER IS A BRILLIANT, TOUGH,
AND THOUGHTFUL LEGISLATOR, IF
THERE WAS A JUST OR RIGHTEOUS
CAUSE THAT NEEDED A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION, YOU KNOW, SHE WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST PEOPLE THAT WOULD
LEAD THE CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA,
COLLEGE ATHLETES HAVE THE RIGHT
TO EARN MONEY FROM THEIR NAME,
IMAGE AND LIKENESS BECAUSE OF
HER, SHE OPENED UP POLICE
MISCONDUCT RECORDS FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 40 YEARS. DURING HER
TENURE, SHE OVERHAULED
CALIFORNIA'S UNJUST FELONY
MURDER RULE, AND SHE ESTABLISHED
THE FIRST IN THE NATION GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS RED FLAG
LAWS, AND SHE ENSURED THAT
COLLEGE STUDENTS K THROUGH 12
STUDENTS HAD ACCESS TO FOOD THE
MOST BASIC THINGS, AND ANYONE
INVOLVED IN THE EAST BAY KNOWS
SENATOR SKINNER. THEY KNOW SHE'S
A PRINCIPLED LEADER WHO'S ALWAYS
THINKING ABOUT THOSE WHO DO NOT
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE. HER
CAREER AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
SPANS 40 YEARS. SO FAR, BERKELEY
CITY COUNCIL, EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK BOARD, ASSEMBLY AND SENATE.
AND WHEN SHE WASN'T AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL, SHE WAS CHAMPIONING
CLIMATE POLICY ACROSS THE
NATION. AGAIN, I SAID, SHE'S
FROM BERKELEY AND SHE WAS THE
ULTIMATE TREE HUGGER IN THE
GALLERY NOW ARE A NUMBER OF
SENATOR SKINNER'S FORMER STAFF,
WHO JUST CLEARLY SHOWS, YOU
KNOW, THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO HONOR HER BECAUSE SHE
HAS SERVED WITH THEM AND THEY
RESPECT THE WORK THAT SHE'S
DOING. AFTER 40 YEARS OF THIS
WORK, SHE HAS ALSO EARNED A
BREAK AND EVEN THOUGH I'VE BEEN
PUSHING HER TO RUN FOR SOMETHING
ELSE, I THINK HER LEGACY IS
GOING TO BE HER PUSHING MORE
WOMEN TO RUN AND GET ELECTED
ACROSS THIS STATE. IN FACT,
WE'RE ON THE BRINK OF PARITY IN
REPRESENTATION OF MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE SENATE. AND SENATOR
SKINNER HAD A HUGE HAND IN THAT
THROUGH HER LEADERSHIP AS CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS, AS WELL AS HER ROLES
ENCOURAGING WOMEN TO RUN FOR
HIGHER OFFICE. AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT SHE WAS
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT SUPPORTED
CONGRESSWOMAN BARBARA LEE TO RUN
FOR OFFICE, AND THE MERE FACT
THAT SHE CONTINUES TO DO THAT
AND CONTINUES TO, YOU KNOW,
ENCOURAGE OTHER WOMEN TO RUN,
CLEARLY SHOWS WHAT SHE VALUES
MOST, AND THAT IS
REPRESENTATION. SHE REPRESENTS
HER DISTRICT WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND
AUTHENTICALLY, AND SHE HAS
CONTINUED TO HOLD THE DOOR OPEN
FOR EVERYONE ELSE TO FOLLOW, AND
MAKING SPACE FOR MANY OF US TO
BE THE WOMEN TO HELP OTHERS. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE,
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
BRIEFLY, BEFORE I START
RECOGNIZING SKINNER. SKINNER, I
JUST WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
RECOGNIZING MY STAFF AND MY
REMARKS. I WOULDN'T BE HERE
WITHOUT MY TREMENDOUS STAFF,
BOTH CURRENT AND PAST. SO THANK
YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE DONE.
NOW, IT'S TRULY AN HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE AN AMAZING COLLEAGUE,
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO I CONSIDER A
FRIEND, SOMEONE WHO I CONSIDER A
RIDE OR DIE MEMBER OF THE SENATE.
AND THAT'S NONE OTHER THAN NANCY
SKINNER. I HAVE SERVED LONGER
WITH NANCY THAN ANY MEMBER ON
THIS FLOOR. WE STARTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY TOGETHER, BUT I GOT
THERE NINE MONTHS AFTER AND IN A
SPECIAL ELECTION, AND I DIDN'T
KNOW UP FROM DOWN. AND IT WAS
INDIVIDUALS LIKE NANCY SKINNER
THAT QUICKLY REACHED OUT TO ME,
EMBRACED ME, GAVE ME THE LAY OF
THE LAND, AND WE SPENT MANY OF
HOURS OUT ON THE PORTICO JUST
SHARING STORIES. WE HAVE A
SIMILAR BACKGROUND, STARTING IN
LOCAL ELECTED AS LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS. SHE AND THE BERKELEY
CITY COUNCIL. ME AND GARDENA.
AND WE JUST HAD HONEST
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE THAT'S WHO
NANCY SKINNER IS. SHE'S A
STRAIGHT TALKER. IT'S NØ, YOU
KNOW, SHE CUT STRAIGHT TO THE
CHASE. WHAT? SHE SAYS YOU CAN GO
TO THE BANK. AND WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT A RIDE OR DIE, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LOOK OVER YOUR SHOULDER
TO SEE IF NANCY'S THERE BECAUSE
MORE THAN LIKELY, SHE'S IN FRONT
OF YOU DOING THE BLOCKING AND
TACKLING. SHE'S OUT THERE
ADVOCATING FOR THE THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE THE MOST,
WHETHER IT'S YOURS, YOUR BILL,
OR SOMEONE, ANYONE ELSE'S BILL.
IT'S NOT JUST HERS. AND I'VE
BEEN HONORED TO COAUTHOR 15
BILLS WITH NANCY DURING OUR TIME
IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND IN THE
SENATE, AND SHE HAS COAUTHORED
OVER A DOZEN OF MINE AS WELL.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT NIL. IT WAS
NANCY WHO CAME TO ME AND SAID,
BRADFORD, LET'S DO THIS TOGETHER.
SHE COULD HAVE EASILY DONE THIS.
BILL BY HERSELF, BUT SHE VALUED
AND UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
COLLABORATION AND WORKING
TOGETHER AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIVERSITY. AND SHE SHARED THAT
SPOTLIGHT WITH ME AND SAID,
LET'S DO THIS TOGETHER, BECAUSE
SHE AGAIN UNDERSTOOD THE VALUE
OF DIVERSITY AND MOVING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD. SHE UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE MAJORITY OF THESE
ATHLETES WHO WERE NOT BEING
COMPENSATED DIDN'T LOOK LIKE
HER. THEY WERE AFRICAN AMERICAN
MEN. AND SO I THANK HER FOR HER
TRUSTING IN ME TO JOIN HER AT
THE HIP ON WHAT WAS A VERY
CHALLENGING PIECE OF LEGISLATION,
A PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT WE
GOT OUT OF THIS HOUSE WITH NOT A
SINGLE NO VOTE. BUT WHEN WE WENT
ON SUMMER RECESS, IT WAS PEOPLE
WHO WERE BLOWING BOTH OUR PHONES
UP TRYING TO GET US TO HOLD THE
BILL AND NOT MOVE IT FURTHER
BECAUSE IT WAS TREMENDOUS
PRESSURE FROM THE NCAA TO DROP
THE BILL AND NANCY AND I HUDDLED
UP AND SHE LAUGHED AND SAID, NO,
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP MOVING
FORWARD. AND THAT'S WHAT WE DID.
AND SO I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THAT. AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT
NANCY, I THINK OF A JEDI
WARRIOR, A WARRIOR FOR JUSTICE,
EQUITY, DIVERSITY, DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION. WHETHER IT'S WOMEN'S
RIGHTS, MINORITY RIGHTS, LGBTQ,
THE HOMELESS, SHE IS A CHAMPION
FOR ALL OF THEM. I'VE BEEN
HONORED TO SERVE WITH HER SINCE
OUR TIME IN THE SENATE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY. SHE WAS OUR CHAIR AND
AFTER LEAVING THE CHAIR OF
PUBLIC SAFETY, SHE BECAME THE
BUDGET CHAIR AT ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT TIMES. PEOPLE SAY WHEN
YOU'RE IN A DEFICIT, BUT
SOMETIMES THE MOST DIFFICULT
TIME WHEN YOU HAVE A LOT OF CASH
AND BEING ABLE TO DISPERSE IT IN
A FAIR AND EQUITABLE WAY. NANCY
WAS A GREAT STEWARD OF THOSE
FUNDS. BUT AGAIN, WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY AND ALL
THAT, WE HAVE DONE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, IT WAS BECAUSE OF
HER COURAGEOUS LEADERSHIP. AND
AGAIN, SHE'S NOT AFRAID TO
TACKLE THE ISSUES THAT MEAN THE
MOST TO ALL CALIFORNIANS,
WHETHER IT'S HOUSING, IMPROVING
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. AS THEY
STATED, EVEN THE ENVIRONMENT AND
I JUST HAVE TRUSTED NANCY SO
MUCH BECAUSE, AGAIN, SHE'S A
STRAIGHT SHOOTER. BUT WE REALLY
BONDED OVER SHOES AND I CALL HER
FANCY NANCY, BUT SHE MIGHT NOT
REMEMBER. WE WERE ON A SAFE
TRIP. MY FIRST YEAR IN THE
SENATE, I MEAN IN ASSEMBLY, AND
WE WERE IN SPAIN AND WE WERE AT
THIS EXCLUSIVE SHOE SHOP, AND IT
WAS OUR LAST DAY TO BE IN THIS
TOWN. AND I SAW A PAIR OF SHOES
FROM MY MOTHER, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, I HAD NOT
CONVERTED MY US MONEY OVER TO
THE CURRENCY THERE, AND I HAD
LEFT MY CREDIT CARD IN MY ROOM
AND THE SHOE SHOP WAS CLOSING
THAT EVENING. NANCY QUICKLY
PULLED OUT HER CREDIT CARD AND
BOUGHT THE SHOES FOR MY MOTHER.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. AND IF
THERE'S ONE INDIVIDUAL ON THIS
FLOOR THAT HAS MORE SHOES THAN
ME IS NONE OTHER THAN FANCY
NANCY, SHE SHE ROCKS THEM LIKE
NOBODY ELSE. WHETHER IT'S
PEARLS, STUDS, RHINESTONES, SHE
HAS ALL THE SHOES FOR ALL
OCCASIONS. SHE'S AGAIN A FASHION
ICON. YOU KNOW, IN HER OWN
STYLE. SHE'S UNAPOLOGETIC FOR
WHAT SHE. WHO SHE IS AND WHAT
SHE DOES. BUT WHAT I ALSO LOVE
ABOUT NANCY IS SHE'S A LOVING
MOTHER, A WIFE, AND A DOTING
GRANDMOTHER NOW. AND AS YOU SAW
AND HEARD WITH HER TREMENDOUS
TRIBUTE TO HER LATE BROTHER, SHE
TELLS YOU WHAT KIND OF PERSON
SHE HAS. SHE HAS A HEART OF
GOLD. SHE CARES ABOUT PEOPLE
MORE THAN SHE CARES ABOUT
HERSELF. SHE HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS COLLEAGUE TO EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US HERE. I HAVE NO
DOUBT THAT SHE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO AMAZING THINGS BECAUSE SHE
LEADS WITH HER HEART. SHE'S
NEVER ONE TO PUT HER FINGER IN
THE WIND AND SEE WHICH WAY IT'S
BLOWING, BECAUSE HER NORTH STAR
LEADS TO JUSTICE AT ALL TIMES,
SHE'S AGAIN. SHE IGNORES THE
HEADLINES AND SHE, AS SENATOR
WAHAB SAID, SHE'S AN EXCELLENT
LISTENER, BUT SHE AGAIN TELLS
THE TRUTH. SHE YOU KNOW, SHE'S
GOING TO TELL IT LIKE IT IS. NO,
STRAIGHT UP, NO CHASER. SHE'S
GOING TO TELL YOU, HEY, THIS
MAKES SENSE OR IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FRIENDSHIP, NOT
ONLY TO ME, BUT EVERY MEMBER IN
THIS SENATE, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
PARTY YOU'RE PART OF, WHERE YOU
COME FROM. NANCY CARES ABOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NANCY CARES
ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
I MEAN, THE UNITED STATES. AND
SHE HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS LEADER
BECAUSE SHE LEADS WITH HER
HEART. SHE'S A TRUE PUBLIC
SERVANT AND THANK YOU, NANCY,
FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS SERVICE TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THIS NATION. SENATOR SKINNER.
YES, I STILL DO WEAR MY MASK.
I'M ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAS
A SUSCEPTIBILITY AND SOME ISSUES
AROUND THAT. BUT APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGING ME FOR IT. THANK YOU.
MY COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE FOR ME,
I REALLY AND, I LOVE YOU ALL
THERE. I LOVE YOU GONNA MAKE ME
CRY? I'VE LOVED SERVING IN THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY. IT'S
GIVEN ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
ON ALL THE ISSUES I CARE MOST
PASSIONATELY ABOUT. COMING FROM
THAT HEART. INCOME INEQUALITY,
REMOVING BARRIERS FOR WOMEN SO
WE CAN ACHIEVE ECONOMIC AND
POLITICAL EQUITY, WHICH WE
DESERVE. RESTORING FAIRNESS TO
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM,
REFORMING OUR CRIMINAL SENTENCES
SO THEY'RE PROPORTIONATE TO THE
CRIME THAT WAS COMMITTED AND
ADVANCING CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN ENERGY AND
THE CLIMATE CRISIS. AND, OF
COURSE, HOUSING, HOUSING,
HOUSING. AND FROM THE TIME I WAS
ON THE BERKELEY COUNCIL, I TRIED
TO USE THE POSITION THAT THE
VOTERS GAVE ME TO ACCOMPLISH
POLICY THAT COULD MAKE TANGIBLE
IMPROVEMENTS IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND BE A MODEL AND A CATALYST,
BOTH NATIONALLY AND GLOBALLY.
ALWAYS THOUGHT ABOUT THAT. I'M
VERY PROUD THAT TODAY, PEOPLE
WHO DIDN'T COMMIT MURDER IN
CALIFORNIA DO NOT HAVE TO SERVE
LIFETIME SENTENCES FOR FELONY
MURDER. THEY DON'T. AND ACCESS
TO POLICE MISCONDUCT RECORDS IS
GOING TO HOPEFULLY GET US TO THE
PLACE WHERE OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR POLICE FORCE, THEY TRUST
EACH OTHER. WE NEED THAT.
WITHOUT THAT, WE WON'T HAVE
PUBLIC SAFETY. OUR LIGHTS STAYED
ON DURING THIS HEAT. WAVES
BECAUSE BACK IN 2010, WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY, MY COLLEAGUES
TOOK THE LEAP OF FAITH. WHEN
THERE WAS NO UTILITY GRADE
BATTERY STORAGE AND PASSED AB
2514. AND NOW CALIFORNIA IS THE
WORLD'S LEADER IN BATTERY
STORAGE. SB 330, THE HOUSING
CRISIS ACT. IT ENACTED THE VERY
SIMPLE IDEA THAT HOUSING
APPLICATIONS THAT PLAY BY THE
RULES SHOULD NOT FACE NEW
OBSTACLES OR HAVE TO GET
DELAYED, SO THOSE CHANGES AND
THE MANY CHANGES ALL OF US MADE
TO THE ADU LAWS, THAT'S BEEN THE
GAME CHANGER IN HOUSING. WE'RE
ACTUALLY BUILDING MORE UNITS
LIKE THE ONE IN MY BACKYARD. AND
IF YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK ABOUT
THE STUDENT ATHLETE, BILL, YOU
KNOW THAT I WAS INSPIRED BY
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR, WHO I
FOLLOWED SINCE HE WAS LEW
ALCINDOR PLAYING ON UCLA, AND HE
TALKED ABOUT THE INCREDIBLE SUMS
OF MONEY THAT COLLEGES MADE OFF
THE BACKS OF STUDENT ATHLETES,
PRIMARILY AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GARDENA POINTED OUT, BLACK
STUDENT ATHLETES, A MESSAGE THAT
WAS REINFORCED TO ME. THEN WHEN
I WAS AT CAL BY DOCTOR HARRY
EDWARDS. BUT I REALLY COULDN'T
IMAGINE THAT I'D BE ABLE TO OR
WE'D BE ABLE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT. YET LOOK WHAT WE DID.
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS. WE DID
THAT THROUGH THE BUDGET.
MOMNIBUS SHOWING, MAKING
CHANGES, ACKNOWLEDGING THE FACT
THAT OUR BLACK WOMEN AND THEIR
BABIES SUFFER MUCH HIGHER
MORTALITY RATES. WE DID THAT IN
THE BUDGET ALSO, GETTING
INTERNET RETAILERS TO COLLECT
SALES TAX. IMAGINE WHAT KIND OF
REVENUE SHORTFALLS WE'D HAVE IF
WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT. THE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER, A
WHOLE LOT MORE. I COULD GO ON OR
ON MY BIG TOP TEN LIST, BUT
WE'LL LET THAT GO FOR NOW. I WAS
ESPECIALLY PROUD TO BE PART OF A
VERY COORDINATED EFFORTS THAT MY
MANY OF MY WOMEN COLLEAGUES HERE
AND WHO SERVED WITH ME IN THE
PAST TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
WOMEN IN THE LEGISLATURE. AND AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED, WE DID IT.
WE DID IT. WE STARTED OUT WITH
ONLY ABOUT 20 OR SO WHEN WE GOT
ELECTED. MANY OF US, AND NOW
WE'RE AT 50. NEXT YEAR WILL BE
58 PRETTY SOON. WE DON'T WANT
JUST PARITY. SORRY, APOLOGIES.
BUT YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE WOMEN.
THANK YOU. YEAH. ANYWAY, I HAVE
TO THANK MY INCREDIBLE STAFF.
AND WHEN I SAY STAFF, I'M
TALKING ALL MY DISTRICT STAFF,
MY PERSON, MY CAPITOL STAFF, MY
COMMITTEE STAFF, BOTH IN THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY. SO MANY
OF THEM ARE HERE TODAY. AGAIN, I
LOVE YOU ALL. THANK YOU FOR
TRUSTING ME, FOR BEING PART OF
TEAM SKINNER, FOR MAKING ME LOOK
GOOD. THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS TOOK
ALL OF US, ALL OF US. AND WE
WERE AIDED BY THE VERY BEST
DISTRICT IN THE STATE. SORRY,
EXPERT AND ACTIVE CONSTITUENTS
WHO BROUGHT US REMARKABLE POLICY
IDEAS AND ALWAYS HAD OUR BACKS,
ALWAYS. AND I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATE STAFF IN ALL LEVELS,
LEADERSHIP, STAFF, DESK STAFF,
THE SECRETARY'S STAFF, OUR
SERGEANTS, ALL OF YOU, FOR THE
SUPPORT YOU'VE PROVIDED US. IT'S
HOW WE GET WHAT WE DO DONE. AND
AS I'VE SAID MANY TIMES, BEING
IN THE LEGISLATURE IS A TEAM
SPORT. THANK YOU, COLLEAGUES,
FOR BEING SUCH GOOD SPORTS, FOR
PLAYING THIS GAME FAIRLY AND
PUTTING YOUR TRUST IN ME. WHEN I
THREW YOU A FASTBALL, OUR
CONSTITUENTS WANT US TO BE
LEADERS. THEY WANT US TO BE
COURAGEOUS. THEY WANT US TO BE
BOLD, NOT JUST FOLLOWING, NOT
JUST LOOKING AT WHAT'S POPULAR,
BUT BEING BOLD AND TAKING THE
LONG VIEW. SO PLEASE DO THAT.
I'M COUNTING ON YOU AND THANK
YOU. I LOVE YOU ALL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, SENATOR SKINNER. WE
LOVE YOU TOO.
THE LAST MEMBER WE WILL BE
RECOGNIZING TODAY.
RECOGNIZING TODAY IS THE SENATOR
WHO REPRESENTS DISTRICT 21,
SENATOR WILK. SENATOR PORTANTINO
WILL BE THE FIRST SPEAKER. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. IT IS
INDEED AN HONOR TO SPEAK ABOUT
MY FRIEND, SENATOR WILK. YOU
KNOW, WHEN I WAS IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY ONE TIME, WE GOT
TREATED TO A SERIES OF POLL
RESULTS ABOUT WHAT CALIFORNIANS
WANTED DURING THE BUDGET CRISIS
AND LO AND BEHOLD, 85% OF
CALIFORNIANS WANTED THE
LEGISLATURE TO SET ASIDE ITS
DIFFERENCES AND WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO GET THINGS
DONE. THEN THEY SHOWED US
ANOTHER POLL THAT WAS 87% OF
CALIFORNIANS WANTED US TO BE
PRODUCTIVE AND WORK TOGETHER TO
ACCOMPLISH A SOLUTION TO THE
BUDGET CRISIS. SO AFTER
RECEIVING THIS DYNAMIC POLL
RESULTS ABOUT THE NATURE OF THE
PUBLIC, WE GOT OUR TALKING
POINTS AND OUR TALKING POINTS
WERE THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THE POLL RESULTS WERE. OUR
TALKING POINTS WERE HOW BAD THE
OTHER SIDE WAS, AND HOW
OBSTRUCTIONIST THEY WERE, AND
HOW THEY PREVENTED US FROM
SOLVING THE PROBLEM. ENTER SCOTT
WILK. HE'S SOMEONE WHO FOCUSES
ON SOLVING PROBLEMS. HE'S
SOMEBODY THAT TAKES TO HEART,
WHAT 85% OF CALIFORNIANS WANT,
WHICH IS COLLABORATION, WHICH IS
GETTING THINGS DONE, WHICH IS
PUTTING PRINCIPLE AHEAD OF
POLITICS. AND HE WAS ABLE TO
LEAD WITH THAT VALUE SET. AND SO
WHEN I SAY TO ALL OF US, WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT WHEN WE SIT IN OUR
CHAIRS, HOW OFTEN DOES ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES COME TO US AND
ASK US FOR HELP? WELL, SCOTT'S
PROBABLY THE PERSON WHO GETS THE
MOST VISITS FROM OTHER MEMBERS
ASKING FOR HELP, AND THAT'S
BECAUSE HE'S WILLING TO HELP.
HE'S WILLING TO STRETCH. IT'S
BECAUSE HIS BASIC PHILOSOPHY IS
TO PUT THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
STATE AHEAD OF PARTIZAN
POLITICS. AND IF WE THINK ABOUT
THE DYNAMIC IN OUR COUNTRY, HOW
RARE IS THAT? HOW RARE IS THAT?
HOW RARE IS IT TO HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO NOT JUST GOT ELECTED, BUT
ASCENDED TO A LEADERSHIP
POSITION WITH THE PERSPECTIVE OF
PUTTING PRINCIPLE AHEAD OF
POLITICS? AND SO FOR ME, THIS IS
AN EASY PERSON TO TALK ABOUT.
HE'S A FRIEND. HE'S A COLLEAGUE.
WE'RE TRUE ON DIFFERENT SIDES OF
THE POLITICAL POLITICAL
SPECTRUM, BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER BECAUSE OF HIS
LEADERSHIP. NOW, WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT ARMENIA. HERE'S
A MAN WHO EMBRACED THE ARMENIAN
CULTURE, NOT JUST FROM A
POLITICAL PERSPECTIVE, BUT FROM
A FAMILY PERSPECTIVE. AND HE
LOVES THAT COUNTRY. AND I
BELIEVE YOU'VE HAD BOTH OF YOUR
CHILDREN BAPTIZED IN ARMENIA.
AND I WILL SUBMIT THAT YOUR
MOTHER IN LAW LIKES YOU BETTER
THAN SHE LIKES ME. I WILL SUBMIT
THAT FOR THE RECORD, BUT I THINK
I'M NUMBER TWO AS FAR AS HER
FAVORITE SENATOR GOES. BUT WE'VE
SHARED A GOOD CAMARADERIE OVER
THAT. THIS IS A MAN WHO DEEPLY
CARES ABOUT ANIMALS. NOW, IN
YOUR BIO, IT LISTS YOUR LOVE OF
YOUR DOGS AHEAD OF YOUR SPOILING
YOUR GRANDCHILDREN. SO I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S THE RIGHT ORDER
OR NOT, BUT YOU NEED TO UPDATE
THAT BECAUSE HE IS ALSO A DEVOUT
GRANDPA TO HIS TWO GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AS WELL. AND HE
DOES SPOIL THE DOGS AND HIS
LEGISLATIVE RECORD SHOWS NOT
JUST SUPPORTING ANIMALS, BUT
ANIMAL SHELTERS, FOSTER YOUTH
EDUCATION, TRANSPARENCY, MAKING
THIS PLACE A BETTER PLACE TO
FUNCTION. AGAIN, THOSE ARE AN
EXTENSION OF HIS VALUES AND HIS
LEADERSHIP, HE'S A DEVOUT MAN,
SOMETHING THAT, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU TALK TO HIM, BUT HE DOESN'T
ESPOUSE IT IN A WAY WHERE HE'S
TRYING TO CONVINCE OTHER PEOPLE.
HE'S REFLECTING HIS OWN DEVOUT
VALUES. THAT'S RARE, AND THAT'S
WHY HE IS WHO HE IS. SO FOR ME
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
OUR LOVE OF ARMENIA, OUR LOVE OF
FAMILY, OUR EMPHASIS ON POLICY,
IT'S BEEN A RARE PRIVILEGE TO
SERVE WITH SOMEBODY ACROSS THE
AISLE WHO IS SO SPECIAL IN DOING
THAT. AND THEN FINALLY, WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HIS
ROLE IN THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
AND, AND ONE YEAR OPPOSING A
BILL, THE NEXT YEAR SUPPORTING A
BILL. AGAIN, THAT'S A TESTAMENT
TO HIM AS A LEADER WHERE HE'S
WILLING TO LOOK AT THE DATA AND
THE FACTS AND THE HISTORY OF
WHAT MAKES STUDENTS PERFORM
BETTER TO WHERE HE SAYS, YOU
KNOW WHAT? MAYBE I DIDN'T GET IT
RIGHT LAST YEAR. NOW I'VE HAD A
BETTER CHANCE TO LOOK. HOW MANY
OF US ADMIT TO CHANGING OUR VOTE
BASED ON THOSE REASONS OF DOING
MORE RESEARCH? AND HOW MANY OF
US STICK TO OUR GUNS AND SAY,
WELL, I VOTE. I WANT TO BE
CONSISTENT. THIS IS A MAN WHO IS
WILLING TO UNDO SOMETHING THAT
HE DID THE YEAR BEFORE BECAUSE
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO. AND
SO IT'S AN HONOR TO STAND HERE
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR FRIENDSHIP,
TO COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP, AND TO JUST SAY TO
EVERYONE, THERE IS A WAY IN THIS
BUSINESS TO BE SUCCESSFUL, TO BE
PRINCIPLED, TO BE VALUED BY
LEADING AND STANDING BY YOUR
CONVICTIONS. AND THAT IS WHAT
SCOTT WILK HAS DONE. HIS ENTIRE
TIME IN OFFICE. AND SO THANK YOU
FOR BEING YOU. THANK YOU FOR
BEING MY FRIEND. AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING A FINE SENATOR IN THIS
AUGUST BODY. SENATOR GLAZER,
YOU'RE THE NEXT SPEAKER. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TO TESTIFY
TO THE GREAT SPIRITS AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF SENATOR SCOTT
WILK. HE SPOKE EARLIER TODAY
THIS AFTERNOON ABOUT HIS WORK ON
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE, WHICH I HAD A FIRST
HAND LOOK AT. YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
TIMES PEOPLE COME UP HERE TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITH A LOT OF
RHETORIC SWIRLING IN THEIR
HEADS, AND IT REALLY ISN'T
REALLY GROUNDED TO THEM OR US.
AND IT REALLY JUST IS HOLLOW
RHETORIC ABOUT WORKING TOGETHER.
AND BIPARTISANSHIP. BUT I HAVE
HAD THAT SAME FRONT ROW SEAT, AS
SENATOR PORTENTINO HAS
INDICATED, OF A VERY PRAGMATIC
POLITICIAN. BUT HE DIDN'T HE
DIDN'T COME UP HERE TO BE AN
ACTIVIST. AND AGAIN, EASY TO
SAY. BUT THEN YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE WORK AND IT'S SENATOR
ATKINS HAS SAID QUITE OFTEN, YOU
KNOW, YOU GOT TO DO THE WORK.
AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT SENATOR
WILKES SERVICE HERE IN THE
SENATE, I HAVE A FIRST HAND VIEW
OF HIM DOING THE WORK FOCUSED ON
PROBLEM SOLVING, FOCUSING ON
POLICY, FOCUSING ON, THE WORK
ABOVE, ABOVE PARTIZANSHIP. AND
THAT WAS THE EXAMPLE HE SPOKE TO
EARLIER TODAY ABOUT THE NURSE
PRACTITIONER BILL, SOMETHING
THAT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT, BILL
TO GO UP ON. YET HE KNEW THE
PRAGMATIC SIDE OF IT. AND IF WE
COULD TALK TO HIM AND LISTEN TO
HIM AND COMPROMISE WITH HIM, YOU
COULD ALWAYS COUNT ON SENATOR
WILK TO BE TRUE TO THAT LOYALTY
AND THAT THAT CONSULTATION AND
THAT COMMUNICATION. AND I HEAR
THAT A LOT FROM OTHERS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE, THAT IF
YOU INVOLVE US, WE CAN BE
PRAGMATIC PROBLEM SOLVERS. AND,
SENATOR WILK, WE HAVE SEEN THAT
FROM YOU. SO MANY, SO MANY
TIMES. SENATOR PORTANTINO TALKED
ABOUT YOUR SERVICE ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, WHICH WE
HAVE SERVED TOGETHER ON FOR MANY
YEARS, AND THAT THERE WAS, AS WE
LIKE TO SAY, IN OUR DISTRICTS,
IT'S NOT A REPUBLICAN OR A
DEMOCRAT POTHOLE. AND IN THE
EDUCATION SPACE, IT'S NOT A
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN CHILD.
IT'S TRYING TO DO WHAT'S
NECESSARY. AND WE KNOW BOTH IN
THAT ARENA AND IN SO MANY
OTHERS, THERE'S INTEREST
POLITICS SWIRLING AROUND.
THERE'S POWER POLITICS SWIRLING
AROUND. BUT IT WAS NEVER
SOMETHING THAT MOTIVATED YOU IN
LOOKING AT A PROBLEM AND LOOKING
AT AN ISSUE. AND I SO, SO
RESPECTED THAT. AND OF COURSE,
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY YOU WERE
SUCH A GOOD FIT FOR THE PROBLEM
SOLVERS CAUCUS. I YOU SERVED AS
VICE CHAIR. DID YOU EVER GET A
CHANCE TO BE CHAIR OR. NO.
THAT'S ALL THEY WOULD GIVE YOU.
OH, I SEE CO-CHAIR THAT. BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WHEN YOU WANT
TO LOOK AT SERVICE HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND SAY, WHERE IS
THE COURAGE, A LOT OF TIMES THE
COURAGE IS IN STANDING UP TO
INTEREST GROUPS. BUT ANOTHER
TIME, WHEN YOU SEE COURAGE, IT'S
WHEN YOU STAND UP FOR PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE A VOICE. THE
POWERLESS. THEY HAVE NO LOBBY.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY CLOUT.
YOU'RE DOING IT FOR THE RIGHT
REASONS. AND WHEN I LOOK AT YOUR
RESUME AND SEE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE IN REGARD TO
ANIMALS, THERE'S NOT A BIG,
POWERFUL CONSTITUENCY FOR
ANIMALS. WHEN I SEE THE WORK
THAT YOU HAVE DONE FOR FOSTER
YOUTH, THERE'S NO POWERFUL
CONSTITUENCY FIGHTING FOR FOSTER
YOUTH UP HERE. THE DISABLED
COMMUNITY AGAIN, ALL THESE
PLACES THAT WE ALL KNOW AS
LEGISLATORS WHERE WE IT'S VERY
EASY TO IDENTIFY THE POWERFUL.
AND IT'S NOT SO DIFFICULT TO
IDENTIFY THE POWERLESS. BUT ON
YOUR RESUME TIME AFTER TIME,
I'VE SEEN WHERE YOU HAVE STOOD
AND WHERE YOUR VOTE HAS BEEN
CAST. AND WHEN YOUR LEADERSHIP
HAS BEEN ADVANCED AND IT'S BEEN
IN THOSE PLACES OF THE FOLKS
THAT DON'T HAVE A VOICE AND IT'S
SOMETHING TO RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE. I'VE SEEN THE SAME
THING FOR YOU IN REGARD TO THE
ARTS, SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
AND SENATOR ALLEN SPEAKS TO
QUITE OFTEN ABOUT HOW VALUABLE
THAT IS TO A CIVILIZED WORLD.
THE ARTS THAT MANY PEOPLE
MISUNDERSTAND AND DON'T KNOW,
AND WHAT IT DOES FOR LEARNING
WHAT IT DOES FOR MENTAL HEALTH,
WHAT IT DOES FOR BUILDING
COMMUNITY AND GOOD CULTURE. AND
YOU HAVE BEEN A LEADER IN THAT
SPACE THAT WE APPRECIATE. AND,
YOU KNOW, I, I, I LOOKED AT SOME
OF THE ACCOLADES YOU'VE GOTTEN
OVER THE YEARS, AND I MUST SAY,
A FEW OF THE GROUPS KIND OF
SURPRISED ME. I MEAN, THE EASTER
SEALS. OKAY, I GET THAT. THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL, I KIND
OF GET THAT SOCIAL COMPASSION.
OKAY. IMPORTANT. THE CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN. HERE'S WHERE YOU AND I
HAVE FOUND A LOT OF ALLIANCES IN
TERMS OF TRANSPARENCY AND
HONESTY AND CAMPAIGNS AND
TRACKING MONEY, AND CERTAINLY
ANOTHER ACCOLADE THAT PEOPLE
SURPRISE PEOPLE IS THE IS THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP FROM COMMON CAUSE IN
OTHER PLACE WHERE PEOPLE WOULD
NOT NATURALLY THINK ABOUT
SENATOR SCOTT WILK, BUT IN
INTEGRITY IN GOVERNMENT,
INTEGRITY IN GOVERNMENT. AND
I'VE SEEN THAT FIRSTHAND IN
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE HAVE HAD ON
BILLS IN THAT SPACE. AND I THANK
YOU FOR THAT, BECAUSE I KNOW IT
TOOK LEADERSHIP AND COURAGE TO
JOIN ME IN SOME OF THOSE
EFFORTS, BECAUSE EVERY EVERYBODY
ELSE DOESN'T LIKE THAT STUFF IN
THE POLITICAL WORLD. BUT YOU AND
I HAVE BOTH BEEN ALIGNED IN THAT
SPACE, AND I APPRECIATE IT, I'VE
NOTED THAT, AND MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE THE SAME
QUALITIES. SO IT'S NOT JUST
EXCLUSIVE TO SENATOR WILK, BUT
INCREDIBLE FIGHTERS FOR YOUR
DISTRICT AND INCREDIBLE LEADERS
IN ACKNOWLEDGING SUCCESS AND
ACCOMPLISHMENT IN YOUR DISTRICT.
AND I'VE SEEN THAT IN YOUR WORK
ON SMALL BUSINESS FOLKS IN YOUR
AREA, NONPROFITS IN YOUR AREA,
THAT ALL THOSE THOSE DO GOODERS
THAT FILL THE GAPS IN OTHER
PLACES OF QUIET VOICES AND, AND
YOUR ABILITY TO SEE THAT IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND, AND RAISE THEM UP
AND PRAISE THEM IS SOMETHING
THAT I KNOW MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES TRY TO DO. AND YOU
HAVE DONE IT IN NUMEROUS WAYS.
NOW I WANT TO JUST SPEAK TO A
FIGHT THAT YOU HAD THAT IT'S
NOTEWORTHY ON A VARIETY OF
LEVELS, BUT YOU FIGHT WITH LA
COUNTY A LITTLE BIT. DON'T YOU?
JUST A LITTLE BIT, AND YOU'RE A
FIGHTER FOR YOUR DISTRICT. AND I
KNOW YOU HAD A BILL A WHILE AGO
TO CREATE A NEW WATER AGENCY IN
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY. INCLUDING
A RATEPAYER, RATEPAYER ADVOCATE.
FIRST OF IT'S KIND OF A WATER
AGENCY. AND I KNOW THAT WAS A
GREAT FIGHT, BUT YOUR FIGHT WITH
LA COUNTY WAS INVOLVING THE
HOMELESS AND TRAUMA CENTERS,
RIGHT? YEAH. THAT THEY WEREN'T
GIVING YOU THE FUNDING IN YOUR
NECK OF THE WOODS, AND YOU GOT A
STATE AUDIT DONE TO SEE WHAT THE
FACTS ARE, NOT JUST ONE
LEGISLATOR'S POINT OF VIEW. AND
THROUGH A LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
AND PUBLIC PRESSURE, LA COUNTY
RELENTED AND INCREASED THE
TRAUMA CENTER FUNDING TO
ANTELOPE VALLEY HOSPITAL, WHICH
FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW, HAS
THE FIFTH BUSIEST EMERGENCY ROOM
IN THE COUNTRY. AND FIGHTING FOR
YOUR DISTRICT AND SUCCEEDING.
AND IT'S TO YOUR CREDIT, TO YOUR
TO YOUR GREAT LEADERSHIP, AS I
SUM UP, LET ME JUST SAY I WAS
THINKING ABOUT GOING ROGUE
BECAUSE HE SAYS THAT ALL THE
TIME. AND IT'S LIKE, CAN WE JUST
DO THAT BACK? CAN WE THROW THAT
BACK AT HIM? BUT I GUESS IT
SPEAKS TO YOUR YOUR YOUR HUMOR.
IT'S A DRY WIT, I'LL ADMIT, BUT
YOUR INSIGHT, YOUR ENERGY, YOUR
EXPERIENCE, YOUR HEART, ALL
THESE THINGS WILL BE MISSED BY
ALL OF US. THE GIFT CAUCUS IS
LOSING ITS BEST SOURCE OF MEME
CONTENT. THEY SEEM TO LIKE A LOT
OF YOUR GESTURES AND CHAOS THAT
YOU BRING AT TIMES, BUT LOOK IT.
IT'S BEEN A TRUE HONOR AND
PLEASURE FOR ALL OF US TO WORK
WITH YOU. SENATOR WILK. WE'RE
GOING TO MISS YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'VE BEEN AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THE SUCCESS OF THIS INSTITUTION
OVER THE YEARS. BIPARTISAN
SUCCESS FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE.
SENATOR WILK, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU.
SO I DID NOT WANT TO DO THIS. IN
FACT, I HAD NO INTENTION OF
DOING THIS. AND THEN WE HAD OUR
OUR OUTGOING SENATOR BRIEFING
ALL THOSE THAT ARE DEPARTING.
AND WE HAD THREE SPEAKERS WHO
WERE FORMER SENATORS COME AND
SPEAK, AND ONE WAS ANTHONY
CANNELLA, WHO SAID, I ALWAYS
THOUGHT THAT WAS A SILLY
EXERCISE. I DIDN'T WANT TO DO
IT. AND THEN I DID IT, AND IT'S
LIKE, AND SO ANTHONY TALKED ME
INTO IT. I'M SO GLAD AND I
RESPECT BOTH OF YOU SO MUCH. AND
I REALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS. I SAID I WASN'T
GOING TO CRY. NOW I THINK I AM.
THAT'S BAD. ANYWAY. MY STORY
STARTS. I WAS ON A FAMILY
VACATION IN SACRAMENTO IN THE
STATE OF JEFFERSON WITH MY
FAMILY AND WE WERE IN
SACRAMENTO. YOU KNOW, WE DID
SUTTER'S FORT AND ALL THAT. WE
DID A TOUR OF THE CAPITOL, AND I
WAS SITTING UP THERE, 13 YEARS
OLD, SAYING, THAT'S WHAT I WANT
TO DO. MOSES GOT TO THE PROMISED
LAND QUICKER THAN I GOT TO THE
STATE SENATE. HE DID IT IN 40
YEARS. TOOK ME 44. BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT I REALLY STAND HERE,
REALLY, WITH A WITH A HEART OF
GRATITUDE. THINK ABOUT IT. WE SO
I'M STILL I STILL HAVE THE OLD
DISTRICT AND THE MIGRATION OF
PEOPLE OUT OF CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
COME FROM DISTRICTS LIKE MINE.
IT COMES FROM DISTRICTS LIKE
YOURS. SO I ACTUALLY REPRESENT A
MILLION, 60,000 PEOPLE. SO WE
ALL OF US REPRESENT MORE THAN 12
DIFFERENT UNITED STATES
SENATORS. JUST THINK HOW AWESOME
THAT IS. IT'S REALLY IT'S REALLY
AN HONOR, HONOR TO BE HERE AND
IN MY DISTRICT, I WAS BORN, I
WAS BORN AND RAISED IN THAT
DISTRICT. AND SO LIKE WHEN I
STARTED RUNNING FOR THE SENATE,
I WAS LIKE RUNNING INTO PEOPLE.
I WENT TO KINDERGARTEN WITH IT
WAS IT WAS IT WAS HILARIOUS. AND
I'M NOT I WALK IN HERE EVERY DAY
STILL IN AWE AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE HISTORY OF IT. SO IT
WAS BRETT POMERANTZ. HE DOESN'T
HAVE HIS SHOW ANYMORE. BUT I WAS
GOING ON HIS SHOW ONE DAY AND I
DON'T I DON'T EVEN REMEMBER WHAT
THE TOPIC WAS GOING TO BE, BUT
ALEX VASSAR HAD JUST COME OUT
WITH HIS NEW BOOK, AND IT TURNS
OUT I'M THE 500TH PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY TO HAVE
SERVED IN BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY. SO I LIKE TO START
CRYING ON TV, AND THEN I WAS SO
EXCITED I CALLED MY WIFE. I GO,
HEY, I'M THE 500 PERSON, I WANT
A JERSEY. IT SAYS MR. 500. YOU
KNOW. YEAH. YOU KNOW MY WIFE.
YEAH. THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN. AND IT STILL HASN'T
HAPPENED. BUT, I JUST I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY THAT MAKES MAKES
US LOOK GOOD AND MAKES OUR JOB
SO EASY. SO I WANT TO THANK
BERNIE AND HER STAFF, WHO JUST
DO A PHENOMENAL JOB. SO
PROFESSIONAL. SOMETIMES THEY TRY
TO MESS YOU GUYS UP AND YOU GUYS
DON'T MISS A BEAT, RULES, RULES
COMMITTEE. ERICA. SHE'S LIKE,
GOD, NOTHING HAPPENS IN THIS
BUILDING THAT ERICA DOESN'T KNOW
ABOUT. AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
KEEP ALL THOSE BALLS UP IN THE
AIR, BUT YOU KNOW, GREAT JOB,
SERGEANTS, I LOVE ALL THE
SERGEANTS, BUT I HAVE TO CALL
OUT A COUPLE BY NAME JUST
BECAUSE. SO, CARLOS JIMENEZ HIS.
YOU'RE IN TROUBLE NOW. HIS
PULLED PORK IS AWESOME. AND SO
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS, AS YOU
KNOW, MY WIFE'S BEEN BACK EAST
AND NOT HERE. AND SO HE ALWAYS
DOES PULL PORK FOR 4TH OF JULY.
SO IT'S ONE OF THE, ONE OF THE
FEW THINGS I GET TO LOOK FORWARD
TO. AND THEN SID NEWMAN, MY
SISTER AND HER FAMILY CAME FROM
KNOXVILLE, TENNESSEE, OUR FIRST
SWEARING IN, AND THEY WERE DOWN
AT THAT RECEPTION DOWN IN THE
ROTUNDA, AND THEY WERE
COMPLETELY LOST AND DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO. AND SHE JUST ASKED
SID, SHE MY SISTER DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW WHO SID WAS, BUT ASKED AND
HE GOT THEM UP HERE AND THEY
BONDED ON THE WAY UP. SO HIS
DAUGHTER, AS YOU KNOW, IS A VERY
PROMINENT SOFTBALL PLAYER. SO IS
MY NIECE. SO MY NIECE AT THAT
TIME WAS IN JUNIOR HIGH. TODAY
SHE'S THE FIRST DAY OF COLLEGE
TODAY. THAT'S HOW QUICKLY TIME
GOES. AND JUST A QUICK SHOUT OUT
TO THE SENATOR FROM CANOGA PARK.
YOUR FATHER WAS SO AWESOME WITH
THEM. I MEAN, THEY WERE THEY
WERE SHARING DIALOG TOGETHER ON
HOME ALONE AND DID PHOTOS AND
SHE HAD TO DO A REPORT AND SO
THERE WAS PHOTOS OF THEM
TOGETHER. AND SHE WAS LIKE A
SUPERSTAR BACK HOME. SO THANK
YOU, FATHER, FOR THAT. AND THEN
THESE SPECIAL SERVICES GUYS, DO
THEY NOT REALIZE THAT THEY COULD
WRITE A BOOK AND BE PRETTY
INTERESTING BOOK. AND THEY DON'T
THEY, THEY, THEY ARE SO
CIRCUMSPECT. AND I REALLY,
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. AND THEN
I JUST WANT TO STAFF I MEAN, WE
CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT STAFF. SO I
WANT TO MENTION SOME OF THE
PEOPLE FROM MY ASSEMBLY STAFF,
MY LONGTIME CHIEF OF STAFF,
CURTIS ROLLINS, WHO NOW, AS YOU
KNOW, IS IN THE THIRD HOUSE. AND
HE, DID A GOOD JOB TRYING TO
REIN ME IN. AND THEN MY
SCHEDULER, WHO'S NOW GONE, LISA
JOHNSON. TURNS OUT SHE WAS THE
BEST SCHEDULER I EVER HAD. I
KNEW SHE WAS GOOD. I HAD NO IDEA
HOW GOOD SHE WAS. BUT NOW I'VE
HAD LIKE NINE SCHEDULERS, SO.
AND WHEN SHE LEFT, BOTH VANESSA
AND I STARTED CRYING. SHE'S LIKE
A DAUGHTER TO US. AND THAT. AND
THEN DANIELLE PARSONS, WHO
WORKED WITH ME IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND NOW WORKS FOR THE LEADER
HERE AND SHE NEEDS TO BE A CHIEF
OF STAFF. SHE IS A PHENOMENAL
PERSON. AND THEN I HAVE MY
SENATE STAFF, ACTUALLY CAME. SO
WE HAVE NICK, AND I'M DOING THIS
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE NEED JOBS,
POTENTIALLY NEED JOBS. NICK,
VIVECA I STOLE I STOLE HIM FROM
THE JOHN. I STOLE HIM FROM THE
JOHN AND KEN SHOW. GREAT. ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. SO IF YOU SEE MY
SOCIAL MEDIA AND YOU LIKE IT,
IT'S NOT ME. IT'S HIM. SO DOES
DOES A GREAT JOB. MATT
GALLAGHER, HE'S HIDING BEHIND
THAT. HE SURVIVED FOUR YEARS
WITH THE GREEK SENATOR FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY AS AS
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR. SO IF YOU
CAN DO THAT, YOU CAN DO
ANYTHING. AND HE'S DONE A GREAT
JOB FOR ME. NEW KID ON THE BLOCK.
GAVIN. I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S ANY
GOOD OR NOT BECAUSE HE JUST GOT
HERE, BUT IT'S GOT HE'S GOT
GREAT HAIR, HE'S GOT GREAT HAIR.
AND THEN WE ALREADY MET CONNOR
SLOAN, MY FELLOW THIS YEAR, WHO
REMINDS ME SO MUCH OF ME, IT'S
KIND OF SCARY. AND THEN MY CHIEF
OF STAFF, EILEEN RICKER. HERE'S
THE THING THAT UPSETS ME ABOUT
EILEEN RICKER. NO ONE MENTORED
ME WHEN I CAME OVER INTO THE
ASSEMBLY. I HAD NO IDEA WE GOT
OUR BUDGET AUGMENTED
AUGMENTATIONS BECAUSE I'D
INTERVIEWED HER, BUT SHE WAS
ALREADY WORKING IN THE SENATE. I
PROBABLY COULD HAVE AFFORDED
HER, BUT I DIDN'T KNOW, SO I
DIDN'T. I GOT HER MANY YEARS
LATER. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A MUCH
SMOOTHER RIDE IF I'D HAD EILEEN
THE WHOLE TIME. BUT REALLY,
HOPEFULLY WE STAY IN TOUCH
BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST YOU'RE
REALLY AWESOME. AND THEN I'M
HAPPY TO SEE MY FRIEND CAME. MY
FRIEND CAME ALL THE WAY FROM
AMERICA TO BE WITH US. FORMER
ASSEMBLYMAN DANTE ACOSTA, WHO
REPLACED ME IN THE ASSEMBLY. HE
HAPPENS TO BE IN TOWN TODAY. SO
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THAT. I
ALSO WANT TO APPRECIATE, JUST
HOW WE HOW WE CAN HOW WE CONDUCT
OURSELVES. AND I THINK A BIG
PART OF THAT WAS, WAS UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR ATKINS.
AND NOW MCGUIRE, IN TERMS OF
SENSE OF FAIRNESS AND FAIR PLAY
AND, YOU KNOW, KNOWING WE'RE NOT
ALWAYS GOING TO GET ALONG, BUT
STILL TRYING TO TRYING TO SEEK
THOSE SOLUTIONS AND ALWAYS HAD
TRUST IN HER. AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY, I WOULD NOT BE HERE
WITHOUT MY WIFE VANESSA, WHO IS
AWESOME. AND, I MEAN, SHE
BELIEVED IN ME IN TIMES WHEN I
DIDN'T BELIEVE IN MYSELF. AND I
WOULD NOT BE HERE WITHOUT HER.
JUST FLAT OUT. AND THEN MY KIDS,
I KNOW THERE'S NO PHOTOS OF MY
KIDS IN MY OFFICE. IT'S ALL MY
DOGS OR MY WIFE, SO. BUT I DO
LOVE MY KIDS. I REALLY DO. I
REALLY, THEY'RE JUST NOT AS CUTE
AS MY DOGS. AND SENATE-TV
PORTANTINO MENTIONED TWO
GRANDKIDS. I GOT NUMBER THREE ON
THE WAY, AND IT'S OUR FIRST
GRANDDAUGHTER, AND THAT'S IN
NOVEMBER. SO VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT. SO, SO I'M LOOKING I'M
HONESTLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
GOING HOME. I'M FORTUNATE THAT I
ACTUALLY LOVE MY WIFE AND I LOVE
MY MOTHER IN LAW WHO LIVES WITH
US, WHO TURNS 98 NEXT WEEK.
YEAH. WELL, THE ONLY THING I
LOVE HER AND SHE'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THE ONLY THING SHE HAS WRONG
WITH HER IS SHE HAS HARD OF
HEARING. AND SHE WATCHES TOO
MUCH FOX NEWS, WHICH JUST DRIVES
ME CRAZY. BUT ANYWAY, WITH THAT,
HAPPY, HAPPY TO GO HOME. AND I
WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW, I LEAVE
HERE WITH A FULL HEART. NOW, THE
THINGS I WANTED TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE NEVER HAPPENED. I MEAN, OUR
POLICY DIRECTION. I JUST HAVE A
DIFFERENT I JUST HAVE A
DIFFERENT VISION FOR OUR STATE.
BUT THAT'S OKAY. BUT, YOU KNOW,
WHEN I'M HOME, YOU KNOW, YOU
GUYS ARE FAMOUS IN YOUR
DISTRICT. SOME OF YOU ARE
INFAMOUS IN MINE. AND SOMEBODY
AND I'M NOT NAMING NAMES, BUT
YOU KNOW, AND PEOPLE LIKE BRING
UP, YOU KNOW, AND LIKE I WILL
DEFEND YOU BECAUSE I, BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU AND WE MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT, DIFFERENT
DISAGREEMENTS. YEAH. YOU WERE
LOOKING AT THE RIGHT PLACE IN
SHAKESPEARE, BUT AND THEN AND
THEN THEY'RE INCREDULOUS.
THEY'RE INCREDULOUS THAT, YOU
KNOW, I WOULD DEFEND THAT
PERSON, BUT, YOU KNOW, THEY VIEW
US AS TWO DIMENSIONAL AND WE'RE
ALL THREE DIMENSIONAL. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF YOU. IT'S BEEN BEEN AN
HONOR TO SERVE WITH YOU, I'M
PRETTY SURE. WHAT? I KNOW WHAT
I'M GOING TO BE DOING NEXT,
IT'LL BE BACK HOME, BUT I WILL
BE UP PROBABLY HERE A FEW TIMES
A YEAR. I'M HOPING THAT WE
CONTINUE TO STAY CONNECTED. AND
SO I'LL LEAVE YOU WITH THE
QUOTE. SO THE SECOND MOST FAMOUS
PERSON FROM MY HIGH SCHOOL, AT
LEAST THAT'S MY OPINION, IS
FRANK ZAPPA. AND HE ONCE SAID
IT'S BETTER TO HAVE SOMETHING TO
REMEMBER THAN ANYTHING TO
REGRET. SO THAT KIND OF SUMS UP
MY LEGISLATIVE EXPERIENCE. BUT I
WOULD NOT TRADE IT FOR ANYTHING
IN THE WORLD. AND AGAIN, THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THIS
STATE AND I WISH YOU ALL WELL
GOING FORWARD. AND I JUST I WISH
US ALL INCLUDING THE STATE
SUCCESS. SO THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO PUT SO
MUCH EFFORT AND TIME INTO THE
REMARKS, SO MUCH EFFORT AND TIME
THAT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU
VIOLATED THE TIME RESTRICTION.
BUT I LEARNED SO MUCH, AND WE
ALL LEARNED SO MUCH FROM EACH
AND EVERY MEMBER THAT IS LEAVING
OUR STATE SENATE. FOR NOW. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A BREAK FOR EVERY
MEMBER THAT WE RECOGNIZE. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME UP TO THE BAR,
EVERY MEMBER THAT WAS RECOGNIZED
TODAY, PLEASE COME ON UP FOR A
GROUP PHOTO.
SENATOR DALY, SENATOR MIN.
SENATOR PORTANTINO, THANK YOU.
THE SENATE WILL CONVENE IN
SECONDS.
THE SENATE IS BACK AND READY TO
GO. MEMBERS, IF WE COULD TAKE
OUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR,
WE WILL BE GETTING INTO A FILE
OF 29 BILLS THAT WILL BE TAKING
UP TODAY. THESE ARE SUPPORT
SUPPORT BILLS. THESE ARE SUPPORT
SUPPORT BILLS. WE'RE LOOKING TO
END SESSION AT 6:00 PM. SO
PLEASE ENSURE YOU ARE ON THE
FLOOR FOR THE VOTE. SO WE CAN
GET THROUGH OUR WORK HERE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. WE ARE NOW UNDER
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR AUGUST 12TH,
2024 THROUGH AUGUST 15TH, 2025
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK UNDER A FLOOR
AMENDMENT MOTION. THERE ARE
FLOOR AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK.
THEY WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE 29.1 D.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES FILE
ITEM 361, SB 347, AND FILE ITEM
371. SB 1440. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE 33.1,
JOINT RULE 61 AND 62 WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO MEET. THURSDAY,
AUGUST 22ND, 2024. TO HEAR THE
TRIBAL COMPACTS AFTER THE
DEADLINE AND WITHOUT FOUR DAYS
NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE. THIS
REQUEST HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NOW IS
THE TIME IF TO SENATOR CORTEZ,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
THERE'S A RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE 62 A FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ALLOWING SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB 1038 IN COMMITTEE WITHOUT
FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN THE DAILY
FILE. THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, SENATOR,
SENATOR, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS ITEM. YEAH. WE OPPOSE AND
REQUEST A ROLL CALL. SENATOR
CORTEZ IS ASKING VOTE ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR CIERTO IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ RESOLVED THAT JOINT
RULE 62 A BE SUSPENDED WITH
RESPECT TO AB 1038. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO NO. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY DODD. DALLEY
NO. DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA.
NO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. NO. AYES 31.
NOES NINE. THE MOTION CARRIES.
ANY OTHER MEMBER? SENATOR.
CIERTO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO REMOVE AB
718 FROM THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
DESK IS NOTED. SENATOR HURTADO.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS, I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW. SENATE BILL 1155 FROM
ENGROSSING AND ENROLLING AND
RETURN THE MEASURE TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER ACTION. THE
DESK IS NOTED. SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN SB 552 TO THE ASSEMBLY
FOR FURTHER ACTION, THE DESK HAS
NOTED. MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE,
WE HAVE ITEMS ONE THROUGH 340
UNDER SECOND READING FILE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 13 169.
ASSEMBLY BILL 892. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 2032 15.
ASSEMBLY BILL 548 WILL BE DEEMED
READ UNDER UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
THESE ARE THE ITEMS THAT I
MENTIONED. THE 29 BILLS. WE'RE
GOING TO START OFF WITH THE
FIRST THREE FILE ITEM 352 FILE
ITEM 353 AND 357. SENATOR BECKER
STARTING US OFF. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 382 BY SENATOR BECKER. AN
ACT RELATING TO REAL PROPERTY.
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. 382 IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE AND MAKES SURE
PROSPECTIVE HOME BUYERS ARE
AWARE OF ANY POTENTIAL COSTLY
ELECTRIC SYSTEMS UPGRADES AT THE
TIME OF SALE. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS EXEMPT HOMES SOLD
WITHIN THREE YEARS OF
CONSTRUCTION FROM THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. SEEING NO MIX UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE AYES
40. NÓ ZERO. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. SENATOR ASHBY
IS READY FOR ITEM 353.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 739 BY SENATOR ASHBY. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY
THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR ASHBY.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO PRESENT SB 739, WHICH
ALLOWS THE CITY OF ELK GROVE TO
UTILIZE CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT
RISK CONTRACTS FOR THE
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL ZOO TO MOVE
TO ITS NEW, LARGER HOME IN ELK
GROVE. THIS MODEL ALLOWS THE
CITY TO STREAMLINE THE
CONSTRUCTION PROCESS AND
THEREFORE BETTER CONTROL COSTS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
CRITICAL FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF
THE PROJECT IT SEEKS TO SUPPORT.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
COLLEAGUES, THIS BILL REQUIRES
27 VOTES. ANY DISCUSSION? I SEE
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ DAILY.
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA
PADILLA. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CORTEZ. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE AYES 40. NØ ZERO. ON
THE URGENCY. ON THE URGENCY.
AYES 40. NÓ ZERO FIVE. ITEM 357.
SENATOR WAHAB IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 981 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT RELATING TO SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. SENATOR WAHAB. THANK
YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT SB 981
DIGITAL IDENTITY THEFT, WHICH IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL
REQUIRES SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WITH A
REPORTING MECHANISM FOR DIGITAL
IDENTITY THEFT, AND ENSURES THAT
REPORTED CONTENT IS TEMPORARILY
BLOCKED UNTIL THE DETERMINATION
HAS BEEN MADE BY THE PLATFORM.
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
SIMPLY NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL AND ADJUST THE TIMELINE FOR
COMPLIANCE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. NO DISCUSSION.
COLLEAGUES, THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
ANY OBJECTION? AYES 40. NO.
ZERO. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING. THE
FIRST THREE UP ARE GOING TO BE
FILE ITEM 384, 387 AND 388.
SENATOR PORTANTINO HAS THE FIRST
ONE. HE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 488
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUPILS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU, MADAM PRO
TEM AND SENATORS, FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT AB 438 RELATING TO
RELATING TO INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. THIS BILL
CHANGES THE BEGINNING OF
POST-SECONDARY TRANSITION
PLANNING FOR STUDENTS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS FROM AGE 16 TO
WHEN THE STUDENT ENTERS HIGH
SCHOOL, AND NO LATER THAN AGE
16. THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION, HAS TAKEN AMENDMENTS
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION TO
ALIGN WITH FEDERAL LAW.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. SEEING
NO MIKES UP, THIS ITEM IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES 40.
NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR LAIRD IS PREPARED FOR
ITEM 387. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1797 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WOULD AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT. SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AB 1797 PROPOSES
DESIGNATING THE DUNGENESS CRAB
AS CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL STATE
CRUSTACEAN, HIGHLIGHTING ITS
ECONOMIC SIGNIFICANCE AND
PROMOTING PUBLIC AWARENESS. IT'S
KEY TO OUR ECONOMY. WITH $57
MILLION IN LANDINGS LAST YEAR
AND UP TO 90 IN OTHERS. THERE IS
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR LAIRD.
ANY OBJECTION? ANY DISCUSSION?
I'M SEEING NONE. THIS ITEM IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION?
AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS THE SENATOR
LAIRD. SHOW HE HAS THREE BILLS.
SENATOR LAIRD IS PREPARED FOR
FILE ITEM 388. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SECRETARY OOPS. HAS
TO READ FIRST. OKAY ASSEMBLY
BILL 1850 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT. SENATOR LAIRD,
GIVEN THE TOPIC, I WAS VERY
EAGER TO PRESENT THIS BILL. THIS
BILL WOULD DESIGNATE THE GENUS
ARIOLIMAX AS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SLUG. FOR THOSE OF US THAT
ARE GRADUATES OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA, SANTA CRUZ, IT IS
OUR MASCOT. IT IS THE BANANA
SLUG. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
DO NOT KNOW, THE BANANA SLUG
PLAYS A VITAL ROLE IN
DECOMPOSING ORGANIC MATTER AND
CONSUMING HARMFUL PLANTS SUCH AS
POISON OAK AND DEATH ANGEL
MUSHROOMS. THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
I VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
SLUG? SEEING NONE. THIS ITEM IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES 40. NØ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR LAIRD IS PREPARED FOR
FILE ITEM 399. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. THE ASSEMBLY BILL 2302 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ATTIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THIS BILL WOULD CLARIFY
THE NUMBER OF MEETINGS THAT
MEMBERS OF A LOCAL LEGISLATIVE
BODY CAN PARTICIPATE IN VIA
TELECONFERENCE EACH YEAR, BASED
ON HOW MANY TIMES THE LOCAL BODY
MEETS. IT ALSO DEFINES THE TERM
MEETING TO MEAN ANY NUMBER OF
MEETINGS OF A LEGISLATIVE BODY
THAT BEGIN ON THE SAME CALENDAR
DAY. THE BILL HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION. THERE IS SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I SEE NO
MIX-UP. THIS ITEM IS ONCE AGAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. I SEE NO OBJECTION. AYES
40. NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
THE NEXT THREE UP ARE ITEMS 401,
402, AND 407. SENATOR DURAZZO IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2378 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
SENATOR DURAZZO. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2378 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LISA CALDERON.
THIS BILL WOULD EXEMPT APPROVED
BARTENDING OR MIXOLOGY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FROM
NEEDING AN ABC LICENSE TO SERVE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES AS PART OF
ITS CURRICULUM. LEGAL
UNCERTAINTY HAS PREVENTED
BARTENDING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS FROM OPERATING DESPITE
BEING APPROVED BY THE STATE
WITHOUT AN ABC LICENSE OR
EXEMPTION. APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS CANNOT UTILIZE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES IN THEIR
TRAININGS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THIS ITEM IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES 40.
NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES FIVE
402 IS BY SENATOR SKINNER. SHE
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2904 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. AN
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB 2904
EXTENDS THE TIME FRAME THAT
CITIES MUST INFORM HOMEOWNERS
AND PROPERTY OWNERS PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTING ZONING CODE
UPDATES, AND IT CHANGES THAT
TIMELINE FROM TEN DAYS TO 20
DAYS. PROVIDES HOMEOWNERS THE
TIME TO GRASP HOW ZONING CHANGES
MAY AFFECT THEM AND ENHANCES
TRANSPARENCY IN THAT PROCESS.
THERE'S BEEN BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, I'M
SEEING NO MIX-UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALY.
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CABALLERO GLAZER. AYE.
AYES 39. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR RUBIO IS
PREPARED FOR FIVE 407.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1880 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIS. AN ACT RELATING TO
MINORS. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE
TODAY AS A PROUD COAUTHOR OF AB
1880 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS.
THIS IMPORTANT BILL WILL PROTECT
CHILD PERFORMERS FROM BEING
FINANCIALLY EXPLOITED AND
ABUSED. IT WILL ENSURE THAT
THEIR EARNINGS ARE PROTECTED.
TOO MANY STORIES ARE OUT THERE
OF YOUNG PERFORMERS WHO EARN
MILLIONS DURING THEIR TIME, BUT
FIND THEMSELVES PENNILESS AND
PENNILESS AS ADULTS BECAUSE NO
ONE LOOKED OUT FOR THEM,
INCLUDING SOME PARENTS. THIS
BILL ONLY ENSURES THAT THEY ARE
TAKEN CARE OF. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM, IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ROLL CALL.
ANY OBJECTION? AYES 40. NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT THREE
UP ARE. ITEM 415, 425 AND 427.
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH FOR FILE ON
415 IS READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2590 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES. AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR CHOMBO. MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2590, WHICH WILL RAISE A
PROCUREMENT THRESHOLD FOR SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY, OR SBCTA, FROM
$25,000 TO $100,000, AND WILL
INCREASE THE THRESHOLD FOR
OBTAINING QUOTATIONS FOR
PURCHASES UNDER $100,000 FROM
1000 TO $5000 AT $25,000 AND
$1,000. THE CURRENT LIMITS ARE
TOO LOW, WHICH RESTRICTS SBCTA
ABILITY TO EFFICIENTLY MANAGE
AND OPERATE, LEADING TO DELAYS
AND INCREASED COSTS. THIS IS
BECAUSE THE COST FOR SUPPLIES,
EQUIPMENT, AND MATERIALS HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE
THE 1980S, WHEN THE LIMIT WAS
FIRST ESTABLISHED. AS A RESULT,
MINOR REPAIRS, PROJECTS AND
PURCHASES OFTEN EXCEED THE
$25,000 LIMIT, REQUIRING A
LENGTHY FORMAL BID PROCESS. AB
2590 ENSURES SBCTA CAN MORE
EFFICIENTLY COMPLETE SMALLER
PROJECTS, WHICH WILL ALLOW IT TO
OPERATE IN A COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 40. NO. ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR PADILLA
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ FILE ITEM 425. ASSEMBLY
BILL 22 2234 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERNER. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR PADILLA. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2234 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER. A BILL
THAT HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. IT WOULD AUTHORIZE A
FOUR YEAR OPT IN PILOT PROJECT
IN THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO,
BANNING E-BIKES FOR ANYONE UNDER
THE AGE OF 12, CONSISTENT WITH
DATA FROM THE CONSUMER PRODUCT
SAFETY COMMISSION. THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO AND CITIES WITHIN THE
COUNTY WOULD HAVE TO PASS AN
ORDINANCE OR RESOLUTION TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM, WITH
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS MIRRORING
THE RACIAL AND IDENTITY
PROFILING ACT KNOWN AS RIPA.
E-BIKES ARE BECOMING AN
INCREASINGLY COMMON AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION FOR BOTH
RECREATION AND COMMUTING. IN
AUGUST OF 22, THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD APPROVED AN E-BIKE
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION DUE TO A
233% INCREASE IN ACCIDENTS
INVOLVING E-BIKES AND BICYCLES.
WITH THE CONTINUED POPULARITY OF
E-BIKES, AB 2234 WOULD HELP
REDUCE INCIDENTS AND INCREASE
SAFETY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO MIX-UP.
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NO
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR RUBIO
HAS FILED ITEM 427. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2822
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. AN
ACT RELATING TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2822,
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO RECORD WHEN THEY
HAVE REMOVED A FIREARM OR DEADLY
WEAPON FROM THE SCENE OF A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALL, WHICH
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO IMPROVE DATA
TRACKING AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AROUND EXISTING FIREARM
RELINQUISHMENT EFFORTS. THIS IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION. GIFFORDS,
BRADY, MARCH FOR OUR LIVES, AND
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, AND MANY
MORE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE, THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NO
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NOES ZERO.
MOTION PASSES. THE NEXT THREE ON
DECK ARE 429, FOUR, 34, AND
FINAL ITEM 438. SENATOR ASHBY IS
PREPARED FOR THE FIRST ONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FOR FINAL
ITEM. 429 ASSEMBLY BILL 1246 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEPHANIE
NGUYEN. AN ACT RELATING TO
RETIREMENT. SENATOR ASHBY. MADAM
PRESIDENT, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1246 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STEPHANIE NGUYEN. THIS
BILL ENSURES A RETIRED CALPERS
MEMBER WHO DIVORCES AFTER
RETIREMENT AND SUBSEQUENTLY
REMARRIES CAN DESIGNATE THEIR
NEW SPOUSE AS A BENEFICIARY FOR
THEIR SHARE OF RETIREMENT.
CURRENTLY, DIVORCED PENSIONERS
WHO REMARRY HAVE NO OPTION TO
SAFEGUARD THEIR NEW SPOUSE'S
FUTURE FINANCIAL SECURITY. THIS
BILL WILL NOT IMPACT THE FORMER
SPOUSE'S AWARDED RETIREMENT
BENEFITS IN ANY WAY. THE BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SEEING NO MAKES UP ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. NO OBJECTION. AYES 40. NO.
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
LEMON IS UP WITH ITEM 432.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2225 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. AN ACT TO EVIDENCE.
SENATOR LEMON. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2225 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. AB 2225 WOULD ADD EMS
PROFESSIONALS TO A LIST OF 14
OTHER HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONS
THAT HAVE THEIR PEER REVIEW
RECORDS EXEMPT FROM DISCOVERY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR LEHMAN.
I SEE NO MIKES UP. ITEM IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. I SEE NO
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO ON
FILE ITEM 432, THE MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE AROUND A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF ORDER. AND NOW
GO TO FILE ITEM 462. AND SENATOR
ROBB IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 462.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2715 BY SENATE
MEMBER BERNER AND ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
WAHAB. THANK YOU. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2715 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERNER, WHICH WILL SIMPLY
ADD THREATENS TO CYBERSECURITY
TO THE LIST OF CLOSED SESSION
EXEMPTIONS IN THE BROWN ACT.
CURRENTLY, LOCAL AGENCIES CAN
ALREADY HOLD A CLOSED SESSION TO
DISCUSS SECURITY THREATS OF
PUBLIC BUILDINGS OR OF ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC SERVICES OR THREATS TO
THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT OF ACCESS TO
PUBLIC SERVICES OR PUBLIC
FACILITIES. HOWEVER, CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT EXPLICITLY LIST THREATS
TO CYBER SECURITY AS A REASON TO
MEET IN CLOSED SESSION. AS A
RESULT, LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
POTENTIALLY FORCED TO DISCUSS
CYBER SECURITY THREATS AND
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS IN OPEN
DISCUSSION, WHICH CAN LEAD THEM
TO MORE VULNERABLE ATTACKS. AB
2715 WILL ENSURE AGENCIES REMAIN
PROTECTED BY DISCUSSING ANY
POTENTIAL CYBERSECURITY THREAT
AND VULNERABILITY IN A CLOSED
SESSION, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. I ALSO SEE NO OBJECTION.
AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES GOING BACK TO OUR
PREVIOUS ORDER, WE HAVE ITEM
438. SENATOR SKINNER FOR ITEM
438. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1810 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRYANT. AN ACT RELATING
TO INCARCERATED PERSONS. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, AB
1810 WILL HELP BRING MENSTRUAL
EQUITY TO OUR STATE PRISONS, OUR
LOCAL JAILS AND OUR JUVENILE
FACILITIES. STATE LAW NOW
REQUIRES THESE PRODUCTS TO BE
SUPPLIED TO INCARCERATED WOMEN
AT NO COST. UPON REQUEST.
HOWEVER, THERE HAVE BEEN CASES
WHERE THESE PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN
WITHHELD, SOMETIMES AS A FORM OF
RETALIATION OR A PUNISHMENT. AND
OF COURSE, THAT CREATES A VERY
HUMILIATING CIRCUMSTANCE FOR THE
PERSON AFFECTED. SO AB 1810 WILL
HELP ADDRESS THAT AND REQUIRE
THAT THE MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS ARE
FREE AND READILY AVAILABLE. WHEN
NEEDED. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THIS I SEE NO
DISCUSSION ON ITEM 438. IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. I SEE NO OBJECTION. AYE'S
40 NÓ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. THE
NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE ITEM
FOUR, 77, FOUR, 86, AND 487.
SENATOR DAHLE PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ITEM 477. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1918 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOOD. AN ACT RELATING TO ENERGY.
SENATOR. DARLING. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, FIRST,
I WANT TO MAKE A CRITICAL
ANNOUNCEMENT. THERE ARE PEACHES
IN THE LOUNGE. GRAB A BAG BEFORE
YOU HEAD OUT. I'M. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 1918 IS A DISTRICT
BILL WHICH HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BOTH IN THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY. THIS
BILL EXEMPTS THE APPLICATION OF
CERTAIN CFC REGULATIONS TO THE
TRINITY PUBLIC UTILITIES
DISTRICT SERVICES TERRITORY AND
TRINITY TRINITY COUNTY. THIS
BILL ADDRESSES TWO CLOSELY
RELATED REGULATORY PROGRAMS THAT
REQUIRE HOMES AND COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS TO BE CONSTRUCTED WITH
SOLAR AND BATTERY SYSTEMS. THIS
PROGRAM MAKES LITTLE, MAKES
LITTLE SENSE IN TRINITY COUNTY
BECAUSE THE UTILITY ALREADY
PROVIDES 100% CARBON FREE
HYDROPOWER TO ITS CUSTOMERS AT
ONE OF THE MOST AFFORDABLE RATES
IN THE STATE. THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL, RATIONAL RATIONALE
FOR AB 1918. ADDITIONALLY, THIS
BILL WOULD RESULT IN NET SAVINGS
FOR THE STATE RATHER THAN
ADDITIONAL FISCAL IMPACTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, I SEE
NO MIX UP FOR FIVE. ITEM 477. IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR DODD, YOU ARE UP
WITH FIVE. ITEM 486. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2905
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE. AN ACT
RELATING TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. SCAMMERS
HAVE EVOLVED THEIR TACTICS USING
AI AND VOICE CLONING TO
IMPERSONATE TRUSTED INDIVIDUALS
AND MANIPULATE VICTIMS INTO
PROVIDING SENSITIVE INFORMATION
OR MAKING FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NØ OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE. NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ITEM IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR BLAKE SPEERS
PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM 47.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3069 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES. AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
BLAKE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB 3069 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN DAVIES AND OUR
SHARED CITY OF OCEANSIDE. THE
NEW FRONT WAVE ARENA IS THE
FIRST LARGE MULTI-PURPOSE
ENTERTAINMENT VENUE IN THE NORTH
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AREA, WHICH
WILL SERVE AS AN ECONOMIC CENTER
OF SPORTS AND RECREATION.
CURRENT LAW LIMITS FRONT WAVE
ARENA FROM DOING WHAT SIMILAR
FACILITIES ALL OVER THE STATE DO,
WHICH IS ADVERTISE WITH LICENSED
ALCOHOL VENDORS. AB 3069 IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO ALLOW FOR AN
EXEMPTION TO THIS RULE FOR THE
NEW FRONT WAVE ARENA THAT IS
OPENING IN OCEANSIDE, THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL AND PASSED SENATE
GO BY 15 ZERO. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO
MIXUP, THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE
URGENCY. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT THREE
UPPER FILE ITEM FIVE, 18, FIVE,
33 AND 542. SENATOR WILK IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ITEM 518. GENERAL ASSEMBLY BILL
1142 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
FONG. AN ACT TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SENATOR WILK THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB
1142 WILL EXTEND THE SUNSET
SUNSET DATE FOR THE CIVIC CENTER
ACT AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES FROM
JANUARY ONE, 2025 TO JANUARY
1ST, 2030. THE CIVIC CENTER ACT
WAS ENACTED IN 2014 BY AB 1906,
WHICH I AUTHORED TO ENSURE THAT
STRUCTURES AND FACILITIES BUILT
WITH PUBLIC FUNDS ARE ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC FOR USES BEYOND
SCHOOL. COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED TO OFFER
THE USE OF FACILITIES AND
GROUNDS TO A VARIETY OF
ORGANIZATIONS, USING A, QUOTE,
FAIR RENTAL VALUE METHOD.
METHODOLOGY. HOWEVER, THE
AUTHORIZATION IS SET TO EXPIRE
AT THE END OF THE YEAR. AB 1142
EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE BY FIVE
YEARS, WHICH WILL ENSURE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS, CLUBS,
AND ASSOCIATIONS ORGANIZED FOR
ATHLETIC ACTIVITIES FOR YOUTH,
CHARITABLE, CHARITABLE PURPOSES
OR THE CIVIC WELL-BEING OF THE
COMMUNITY CAN CAN CONTINUE TO
USE ANY COLLEGE FACILITIES AND
GROUNDS AT MINIMAL TO NO COST
UNTIL JANUARY 1ST, 2030.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR EGGMAN
HAS FILED ITEM 533. SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1991 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS. SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. CALIFORNIA FACES
MAJOR SHORTAGES IN HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. AND SO WE DO A LOT OF
SCHOLARSHIPS, ESPECIALLY FOR
PEOPLE GOING INTO
UNDERREPRESENTED AREAS. BUT WE
DON'T KEEP DATA ON HOW LONG THEY
STAY OR HOW THEY DO. THIS BILL
SIMPLY ASKS IF YOU ARE RENEWING
YOUR LICENSE ONLINE, THAT YOU
PROVIDE YOUR NATIONAL PROVIDER
IDENTIFIER IF THEY HAVE ONE, SO
WE CAN TRACK BETTER AND MAINTAIN
BETTER DATA. I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR NØ MIX
UP ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. AYES 40. NØ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
CUEVAS HAS FILED ITEM 542.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2166 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
SENATOR CUEVAS. OKAY. AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 2166, A BILL TO
INCREASE THE DIVERSITY AND
TRAINING WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL IS
RECEIVING A BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY LICENSE.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT COSMETOLOGY
CURRICULUM FALLS SHORT IN
PREPARING BEAUTY PROFESSIONALS
TO PROFESSIONALS TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH VARYING HAIR
TEXTURES AND TYPES. AN ESTIMATED
65% OF THE U.S. POPULATION HAS
COILED, CURLY, WAVY HAIR, YET
OUR STATE LICENSING AUTHORITIES
DO NOT REQUIRE ANY TRAINING AND
COMPETENCY FOR STYLING TEXTURED
HAIR. THIS INSTITUTIONALIZED GAP
IN KNOWLEDGE CAN RESULT IN HAIR
DAMAGE FOR CLIENTS FROM VARYING
CULTURAL AND ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS,
AS WELL AS LIMITING THE ABILITY
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO RECEIVE THE
SERVICES ALTOGETHER. THE ABSENCE
OF INCLUSIVE HAIR EDUCATION
PERPETUATES NARROW BEAUTY
STANDARDS. FOR THESE REASONS, AB
2116 WOULD REQUIRE COURSES IN
HAIRSTYLING, BARBERING, AND
COSMETOLOGY TO INCLUDE
INSTRUCTION FOR PROVIDING
SERVICES TO PERSONS WITH VARYING
HAIR TYPES, INCLUDING DIFFERENT
TEXTURES, THICKNESSES, CURL, AND
WAVE PATTERNS. ADDITIONALLY, THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE EXAMINATIONS
FOR LICENSURE TO INCLUDE
QUESTIONS ABOUT TEXTURED HAIR,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT, THREE ARE
ON DECK. OUR FINAL ITEM 586, 589
AND 616. SENATOR UMBERG, YOU
HAVE FILED ITEM 596. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1805
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO PUPIL INSTRUCTIONS.
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
REQUIRES THAT STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA LEARN ABOUT OUR
HERITAGE, OUR HERITAGE, IN TERMS
OF THE INTEGRATION OF PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BEFORE THERE WAS BROWN
VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION, THERE
WAS THE MENDEZ CASE. THE MENDEZ
FAMILY WAS A FAMILY IN
WESTMINSTER WHOSE CHILDREN WERE
LATINO AND WERE NOT PERMITTED TO
GO TO THE SCHOOL WITH WHITE
STUDENTS, THEIR PARENTS AND FOUR
OTHER FAMILIES TOOK UP THE CAUSE
AND TOOK IT TO THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT. MENDEZ VERSUS
WESTMINSTER IS A SEMINAL CASE.
LANGUAGE FROM THAT CASE WAS
ACTUALLY QUOTED IN BROWN VERSUS
BOARD OF EDUCATION. I WANT TO
PARTICULARLY THANK SYLVIA AND
SANDRA MENDEZ, THE DAUGHTERS OF
GONZALO AND FELICITAS MENDEZ,
FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP ON THIS
LEGISLATION. SYLVIA HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS ADVOCATE FOR ENSURING
THAT CALIFORNIANS KNOW OF THEIR
HERITAGE AND KNOW OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS MATTER. I
URGE, AND I VOTE NO MIX UP ITEM
IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES SEN. BECKER HAS
FILED ITEM 599. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3119 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS.
SENATOR BECKER, I THANK YOU. I'M
PRESENTING AB 3119 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOWE. THIS IS A
SIMPLE BILL THAT REQUESTS
VARIOUS HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING BOARDS TO CONSIDER
INCORPORATING A CONTINUING
EDUCATION COURSE IN INFECTION
ASSOCIATED CHRONIC CONDITIONS,
INCLUDING LONG COVID. OVER 400
MILLION PEOPLE WORLDWIDE AND 16
MILLION IN THE US HAVE LONG
COVID. THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 40. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR ALLEN IS
PREPARED FOR ITEM 616.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2590 99 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS. AN
ACT RELATING TO WATER. SENATOR
ALLEN. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. YOU'RE DOING LA PROUD
UP THERE. THIS IS AN OMNIBUS
COMMITTEE BILL MAKING TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO CODE RELATED TO WATER
QUALITY AND DRINKING WATER. IT'S
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
NO DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. STILL NO OBJECTION.
FANTASTIC. AYES 40. NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES THE FINAL THREE
ITEMS ON OUR ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING ARE FIVE. ITEM SIX, 45,
SIX, 47, AND 491. SENATOR
HURTADO IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2864
BY SUDDENLY MEMBER GARCIA. AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
HURTADO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. PRESIDENT, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2864. THIS BILL HAS
SUPPORT, SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR SEEING NO MIX
UP. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WITH AN
URGENCY. NO OBJECTION ON THE
URGENCY. AYES 40. NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
CABALLERO HAS FILED ITEM 647.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2721 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE AND
RELATING TO FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE, AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR. SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
TODAY AB 2721 THE ASSEMBLY
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE OMNIBUS
BILL FOR 2024. THE BILL EXTENDS
TO 2030. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE CDVA CFAS PROGRAM TO
LICENSE AND ENFORCE ISSUES
RELATED TO INEDIBLE KITCHEN
GREASE, AND IT WILL ALLOW CFA'S
PRODUCE SAFETY PROGRAM TO COMPLY
WITH THE USDA'S PRODUCE SAFETY
RULES. AND FINALLY, IT WILL ALSO
ALLOW CDFA TO DEFINE GRAPE
PRICING DISTRICTS IN THE STATE.
IF A COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT
RELATED TO FEDERAL STATE
COOPERATIVE MARKET NEWS SERVICES
IS NOT IN EFFECT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
AYES 40 ON THE. ON THE URGENCY.
AYES 40. ON THE ITEM MEASURE.
PASSES ON THE URGENCY. I JUST
DID.
OUR NEXT UP IS FILE ON 491
PRESENTED BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2479 BY SENATOR MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
SENATOR MENGIBAR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SHARON QUIRK-SILVA FOR AB 2579.
THAT IS GRANTING BUILDING OWNERS
WITH THREE OR MORE MULTIFAMILY
DWELLING UNITS A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION FOR EXTERIOR ELEVATED
ELEMENTS INSPECTION,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. THIS TOOL IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
SEEING NONE. AYES 40. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. AWESOME NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR PADILLA,
YOU'RE PREPARED. PLEASE READ.
MADAM PRESIDENT, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST SB 583 BE RETURNED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. THE DESK HAS NOTED.
NOTHING FURTHER. UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS. MR. PRO TEM, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM PRESIDENT.
FANTASTIC JOB TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND IT WAS TRULY A
BEAUTIFUL TRIBUTE. THE FIRST
SEVEN SENATORS HERE ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO KICK OFF
TOMORROW'S FLOOR SESSION,
ACKNOWLEDGING AND CELEBRATING AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR SENATORS
TOMORROW. THIS BODY SHOULD
EXPECT A BUSY DAY WORK UNTIL
ABOUT 6:00 TOMORROW. SO THIS
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS TOMORROW,
TUESDAY, AUGUST 20TH AT 10 A.M.
AND PLEASE ANTICIPATE WORKING
TILL 6 P.M. TOMORROW. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED. WE WILL RECONVENE
TUESDAY, AUGUST 20TH AT 10 A.M.
GIVE SUPPORTERS IN THE
LEGISLATIVE SOFTBALL GAME GO
SOCAL.